and we are back with another i'm not
gm speed chess championship match amman
i'm so glad to have you back today with what's the
first quarterfinal matchup of this year's edition
yeah the uh the tournaments are you know
very exciting and i am not a gm i always
get this feeling like i can't wait to come back
robert you know i miss a day because the match
happens really early and it's always nice to
be back for the commentary of the next match
for sure and we have a fun one in store for
everyone today because it's lawrence trent
against roberto molina and you know we need to
make some predictions among who are you going
with yeah roberto molino is actually one of the
matches that i didn't commentate the first round
of i've commentated a lot of these matches
but that's one other one i didn't didn't see
so i think he was playing alexia santoramo um he
ended up winning the match pretty convincingly
which is what we might expect but he's actually
a player that i've only really known online so
i played him a lot online in like bullet chess
especially and the most that i know about him he's
a very very tricky bullet player a very strong
bullet player him and i played a lot of matches
so i only really know about his bullet chest
and lawrence i mean i don't think we really got
to see him flex his muscles i mean at the end
of the day robert he only played danny ranch
i won't go so far as to agree with you there
but danny was not in his best shape but lawrence
was extremely impressive but we know that he's
tweeted about wanting to become a grandmaster he
says it's now's the time i'm going to put my mind
to it so if he is taking that task seriously and
he's preparing that means this could be his last
time playing the i'm not gm speeches championship
yeah that's right no i'm very excited to
see lawrence uh take something like the
grand master title seriously i actually saw a
tweet from attila terzo another uh streamer who
said he was going for the gm title so i love to
see this uh dedication from some of the players
to the grand master title and roberto molina
is another guy you know with his style he could
definitely go for the grand master title pretty
soon as well for sure and let's remind everybody
of what we're here for what the format is like
we will have 75 minutes of five minute plus one
second increment blitz followed by 45 minutes of
the three plus one and then ultimately we get to
the bullet chest 25 minutes of that and as is
always the case only one winner will be crowned
today they will move on to the semifinals but i'm
on the prize fund getting bigger so for those who
are still in the competition and they can keep on
going they'll be enjoying this final stretch here
yeah this is a nice nice prize fun for the
players and it then the thing that i like
about it is that it keeps the match interesting
the whole way you know if the match finishes 10 9
where the match finishes you know 20 to zero
that's a much different payout for the players
so i like the format the way that the prizes
are distributed that it keeps the match exciting
for us even if we already know who's gonna uh
you know win the match for sure and let's uh
remind everybody how we got here you mentioned
that roberto he did beat alessia that was in
point odds match he was very impressive to
storm back and lawrence trent probably had
the single most impressive first round because he
at least on paper by seating he was the underdog
but he didn't look any bit that part he was there
to shine against danny wrench and i think when he
plays his quote-unquote nemesis he brings the best
out of him so he wants to play the greg shahadis
of the world and that's why he's playing so well
as he sees greg on the other side of the bracket
he wants them to meet in the final yeah and you
bring up such an interesting point and i think
i think it plays exactly into the character of
lawrence trent i'm actually wondering to your
point whether he views his opponent today in that
light and i don't think he does i don't think that
he really knows that much about his opponent you
know he he can drum up the hype in his usual way
with a few tweets and stuff like that but when
he's playing danny ranch where he's playing greg
shahadi john bartholomew you know you really
as you said it brings the best out of him and
he he thrives in that environment so i feel like
today with with an opponent from brazil that he
might know a bit less about and he's definitely
a very strong solid player in his own right
that uh this could be a very tough match just
stylistically for for lawrence yeah i think that
something can be misleading it's that with an
odds match as roberto played in the first round
you're going to play totally different openings
right if you need to win to catch up you will play
sharper chess you will do different things than if
you're starting zero zero or two to two right so
that's happens in every single sport when you're
back's against the wall you need to play something
for win you need to take risks and so i'm going
to be curious how roberto starts this match and
for lawrence how he manages his clock because
sometimes he goes to think tank and that's when
it spells trouble for many of these players yeah
no that's a that's a great point as well and of
course full full credit to lawrence because people
like to sell danny short you know myself included
but at the end of the day danny's an incredibly
strong player especially when he shows up
um and and lawrence was able to beat him by
a pretty convincing margin so that that match
really says to me that lawrence can can you know
win this whole thing like he's capable of that
um this event so uh florence shows up the same
way he did against danny has those tricky openings
what we noticed from his style in that last match
is that he had opening systems that he really he
really knew and he was willing to play over and
over and danny wasn't able to solve them quickly
and lawrence was getting way up on the clock
and using that to his advantage as we see the
five-minute portion uh just getting underway
and we spoke to kriker mkhitaryan the beloved
uh head of portuguese content for chess.com a
great streamer in his own right and compatriot
of roberto molina he says that roberto goes to
his caracons his tried and true opening and he
says i'm going to stop playing it at some point
and he never does but we have a very strange
start to this with the b2 pawn is that poison
iman or is roberto going to get away with it
um well i think that the answer can be yes and yes
to that to that series of questions uh i think it
is probably one of those poison pawns
where you can see the evaluation bar
on the left-hand side hovering around the the
you know the center of the board which is more
around equal territory and to beat down upon and
still have a position that is around equal usually
indicates that there's pretty good compensation
so i think it is sort of a poison pond variation
lawrence is already starting with
the h-pawn you know knight g to e2
and he's just got easy king-side pressure when
as soon as this knight develops and black castles
you're going to see that bishop come to h6 for for
lawrence and i think this is sort of his styles
more of a more of a tricky sort of blitz type
of opening to be down upon already i agree and
the plans for white actually are pretty easy e5
now actually comes with tempo i wasn't suggested
even if the knight went to e7 now you can go for
g4 eventually knight f4 maybe a sacrifice on g6
and even if some of it is speculative in blitz
chess these kind of sacrifices almost always work
so i would be looking at that kind of quick attack
and there we see lawrence goes right forward and
look at how much more development he has he's all
four minor pieces out there look at black's queen
side completely stuck useless to fend off the
attack that's about to happen and the sacrifice
in the g6 square so knight of fate is a good move
yeah and and the knight going to f6 means that uh
the maybe the more natural development of like
97 knight d7 is impossible so what you're going
to see here is you're going to see some of the
pieces sort of bumping into each other the bishop
on g7 is not that great hitting these pawns black
can't even challenge the center with c5 because
knight b5 knight d6 is always killer so he sort of
has to play like a6 to prepare c5 but at the same
time this bishop needs to get out so you got to
go b6 to get the bishop out there's just so many
different plans that seem to overlap and what
i'm seeing from the position right now is that
black species they don't feel like they can
develop comfortably here and lawrence has you
know one plan and he's just executing it although
knight to e2 now you can't play c5 because
what you were just saying was absolutely correct
that c5 you want to play but can't if the knight
jumps into b5 and into d6 but that knight went
to e2 so now feels like the time to go c5 and
i understand that there will be risk the b5 score
still wipes for the taking with a perhaps a bishop
b5 check but i need to get active i need to free
the c6 square for my knight i need to make sure
i can fully develop otherwise i'm sitting and
doing nothing yep and a6 blade which i think
has to do with exactly that square and probably
the c5 move incoming but i just don't know if you
have time for for moves like this and c4 i i kind
of like as a as a reply he's going to take it and
maybe he's going to try to establish a
knight on d5 but hang on that e4 square
robert just became available after d takes c4
and i think that roberto molina might regret that
he's definitely going gonna regret it because his
bishop on g7 isn't actually doing much of anything
that's like his one developed piece everything
else all of his miners and his rooks on the
first rank the eighth rank in this case so he
brings the knight to d7 i'm already looking what
was that knight doing covering the g6 pawn can
i get away with bishop takes e6 knight takes g6
a sacrifice of a piece for two pawns but you also
get that rook in the corner no he plays well i was
gonna say more tamely but that's a king on g3 so i
don't know if that's very team chess i don't know
what uh he might be thinking like whether he just
wants to bring his king to like the h file like
thinking that it's more castled or more safe over
there i have to say i don't really get this move
because hey the king is so safe on f2 g4 is one
of the main ideas it looks like he might go for
and this kind of stops like both of them it's you
know less safe on g3 more susceptible to checks
i have to say i just don't really don't really
get that move it doesn't look terrible but it
looks unnecessary right it also makes it harder
to attack because if you sacrifice a piece
you're opening up the board and your king is on
g3 so right now knight is coming to d6 that's a
problem i believe that roberto he has to just say
doesn't look great but maybe i should just castle
king side i i think i'm gonna get attacked and
probably check me regardless of what i do so i
he does it but i wouldn't be happy about it
yeah this this castling i i think i feel a
little bit better doing this now that the king
is here though uh in all honesty if that king
was there i'd be like okay g4 is coming and you
know bad things are happening to good people um
g5 great move right instead of just moving the
knight bishop g5 hits the queen establishes the
f6 square as the knights for the taking and yeah
knight f6 check this could be a very quick game
at this point yeah he's he's going to take with
the bishop do you think he's going to take that
or just go king hit man if this king was on f2
this would be game over that's true right because
there are some tactics revolving around
the fact that e5 pawn is pinned well not
as much anymore but there could be one you
play bishop h6 i could take your knight on f6
and you can't take me back so rook c1 what a
calm move and threads to win a pawn on d5 so
developing bishop e6 i don't love rook c1 it feels
like it's giving black time but i see the eval bar
is through the roof yeah i i would move the
king and you know f4 g4 or maybe both of them
those those are the moves i want to do
basically if you play g4 and they take it
h5 will win the game immediately i think getting
that rook involved is checkmate for sure although
because it says like plus nine or whatever i
can't really see it's all the way up knight
takes h5 and bishop f6 probably just leaves the
checkmate knight h5 bishop f6 damn no not even h6
not anymore because the knight came d7 this is why
i didn't like rook c1 it wasn't because i spotted
the tactic right away it's because it took time
and it has a purpose to it but now if i'm roberto
i'm trying to strike back can i play a c5 move
probably not i don't think i have time to do so
but that's the kind of thing that black needs
maybe a queen b6 or you get the point i need
to strike back and now the e5 pawn is hanging in
addition to d4 pawn being under attack definitely
i love queen f4 um first glance type of move sort
of covers both of those pawns at the same time
now the king on g3 makes a lot of sense by the
way so it's not like we can play it right away but
i like queen f4 king g3 if necessary and and sort
of just continue our plan over here uh it goes
queen e3 similar idea i feel like f4 was a little
closer to the action agreed though with gtx h5
the next move to be played it feels like black's
king is going to be harassed no matter what so
this looks like a checkmate on the horizon and
i have to say lawrence has played this game very
well and roberto probably should not go back to
this opening as you said from the get-go this is
lawrence's style and what we spoke about with uh
krikor uh mkhitaryan he was saying that roberto
likes to trade pieces he is of the schooling
of anderson the like of let's trade pieces get
to the end game and i'll play you this is anything
but that anything about that now if you're trading
pieces you're only helping yourself getting get
mated here so he's probably not happy with his
prospects queen e3 nice move let's take stock of
the time as well you know a minute ticking down
for roberto and not only does he have the tougher
position but you know head in his hands right now
on cam he he knows that this is just hopeless
hopeless defensive task and i didn't even notice
this but look at the rating differential
between these two roberto's rating is 27.60
lawrence is 25.70 in blitz that's like 200 rating
points and yet in game one lauren says you think i
care about that number i'm on that path i'm trying
to make progress let me go and just checkmate your
king so rookie played do not take that rook that's
funny right normally you just take a rook with
your knight that sounds like a good trade but just
go for the checkmate don't waste your time yeah no
he he knows okay so bishop takes f6 he wants i
i think he wants uh or roberto rather wants like
bishop takes f6 some sort of queen h6 pawn takes
blundering you know queen d4 it takes f6 but what
he's going to do is he's going to take first with
the pawn on f6 to threaten queen h6 made in two um
must be king g8 to keep playing this game oh just
h takes g6 and h5 i mean all the pawns are coming
this doesn't look very pleasant the nasty
thing is after h5 you're threatening like
almost queen h6 like you could really hurt
the guy bishop g6 is a nice touch from uh
from lawrence as well there and and roberto's
gonna resign what a resounding first game
there from from lawrence robert that was super
impressive he just made a fantastic player look
like he's you know 400 ready points lower and
that goes to show that when lawrence is playing
his best and stylistically when he gets that kind
of position he can really thrive but roberto now
with the white pieces let's see if he can even
the score up we're getting a king's indian defense
this is standard stuff here and i get the feeling
that we're not going to see the sharp lines where
white plays d5 black plays you know the pawn to
f5 and then we have essentially white pushing on
the queen side black trying to check me on the
king side because i feel like roberto does not
want that kind of tactical battle exactly
um so we'll see what he goes for because
to me lawrence is not going to be saying no to
that so we've got one player who's going to agree
to play that sort of style um it just depends how
roberto wants to go and h5 played already i have
to say that seems like a bit of an odd move to me
but i'm sure it's not uh not completely ludicrous
yeah the problem with playing h5 is it makes
some of your other plans more difficult but
in the style of the king's indian if i could
just start marching my pawns at the board
then i can get an attack but the g5 squares
whites for the taking so you have to be careful
before you push up onto h4 white will just
put the bishop one g5 to attack that pawn so
i do prefer white's position them on generally
speaking in these kind of kings indians that are
closed so i feel like roberto has exactly what he
wants definitely rook b1 looking for b4 taking the
c5 square and basically saying that knight on
a6 not participating at all in the game and as
you mentioned each for bishop g5 is is always uh
always a nice way to react um if bishop g5 doesn't
happen i mean you know black's always looking for
ideas like knight h7 try to play f5 or maybe h4
knight h5 um if bishop g5 isn't played to maybe
jump in to the f4 square but i get the feeling
lawrence is kind of on both sides here like he
started playing h5 then he's played c6 i don't
really know which side of the board he's trying to
play on and that can cause confusion for roberto
and you're right that sometimes in order to get
the best attack possible you need to threaten
things on the other side of the board from where
you're attacking but this can't be good for black
look at this pawn on d6 permanent weakness the
bishop on e2 is now a very strong piece whereas
before it was behind that c4 pawn and now the
c4 square is free so knight c4 going right after
the d6 square this looks very bad for black yeah
knight c4 um also means that b4 can happen next
um kicking that knight out right now it looks
like maybe still playable but i wouldn't go for
it because the knight on c3 is loose so b4 is a
little a little risky but knight c4 hitting the
d6 pawn with the knight and especially after his
move queen to f2 he's looking at ideas like knight
c4 and then there's like knight takes e5 knight
takes d6 moves to undermine that knight on c5
yes and what roberto did makes sense he didn't
put the knight c4 yet but he put his work on c1
he's just using the queen side and this is how
the king's inning goes except for the fact that
black's attack never got started right normally
your pawn's already on f5 and you're going for
something on the queen side here white is just
first knight c4 now knight to b6 coming next
this looks so good for roberto it really does
um sometimes in these positions you have to
um you know give thought to move b5 which actually
keeps your bishop trapped behind enemy lines
sometimes that bishop just simply doesn't get out
again so b5 something to consider you mentioned
knight b6 makes a ton of sense um yeah at this
point he's just taking over the c file and we
talked about trading those pieces in game one
this looks like a lot more in that style black
is not getting a dangerous attack when you know
half his attackers just got traded off the board
that's right and this bishop on g7 remains a
permanent problem so don't be surprised when
lawrence tries bishop f6 bishop g5 because this
is the downside of the king's inu when you upon
as they say bad bishops they're good pawns your e5
pawn is great but your bishop one g7 is not doing
very well so i like white's position but you do
need to be careful for example for the queen b5
trying to go all in on the queen side if black can
quickly muster some counter play on the king side
that could spell some trouble and i i think bishop
f6 bishop g5 it's a little slow but if you can
accomplish that the dark squares around the white
king could be in danger yeah and it's so easy to
you know go queen b5 and after they take on e4 go
queen h4 knight f6 knight g4 e4 pawn is hanging
it's really easy for the counter play to arrive
so so quick so he's actually taken on f5 probably
because he saw pawn takes e4 and some of those
moves i was talking about and it's not so clear
how to defend that e pawn when it's all alone
there that's right and this may look bad for white
and since the d5 pawn is isolated but you already
have all the defenders you need for that pawn
and e4 is a good move because that bishop on g7
i was laughing at it now it looks great that's
not a long diagonal and as you said knight f6
knight g4 queen h4 all these moves might happen
so i would start with knight f6 and i think that
induces h3 from white but that hurts the king side
yep yeah we might see like an h4 after that uh as
white the the thing you like maybe about knight f6
is that it stops queen h4 so then it makes a move
like queen c7 you know 10 times more attractive
that you you almost forced that that queen
trade or you'd like to think and then you're
also attacking these pawns on the queen side i
think if the queen's disappeared here then uh
roberto molina can execute his plan of like brooks
c7 you know get this pawn and try to promote that
guy there's just one issue at the current moment
that if knight f6 happens and queen c7 i will
trade queens and play knight g4 your knight on
b6 is on the same diagonal as your king so there
will be bishop d4 check ideas in those lines and
that's actually pretty crazy because it seems like
white's you know all safe and sound but at the
end of the day notice when pieces on the same
diagonals each other that could backfire yeah rook
f7 played so uh unfortunately lawrence was maybe
not thinking tactically enough could have got away
with the knight first but he recognizes that hey
those queens come off this could be bad news for
me so he wants to stop the invasion there he has
given up the c8 square which has been used queen
c8 check um and if the rook gets to c7 obviously
that would be uh very very good for white but
i'm not quite sure how that can happen bishop f8
but the thing about this is if you played
bishop effete or knight of fate you just
worsen your piece you would love to play king h7
here if the knight were already on f6 your king
would have an escape square although the f5 pawn
would be hanging but the rook didn't have to leave
that fate i guess that's the essential point of
this black is now tied down again right what what
are your next two moves for black like king h7 and
maybe knight g6 or something like that right yeah
maybe king king h7 but it's not the fastest no
it's not it doesn't feel like it has that kind
of force so if i am roberto here i may even just
think can i push my pawn to b6 somehow can i play
b5 move my knight play pawn b6 maybe knight to a5
go after your b7 pawn it's a lot to ask for but i
think that black is much slower in the approach
now that you had to retreat your knight to f8
yep no that's a good point like as soon as
the rook gets to c7 it feels really good i'm
almost looking at knight a8 rook c7 like as
strange as it is just to get the rook there
and then it looks like you win that pawn on
v7 i kind of like knight eight it's funky it
may not be objectively the best move but it
has that clear purpose as you're saying and
you can also push the b pawn up establish that
rook on c7 and i'm not sure how black intends
to meet that yeah it's just like um the the
way that i would be afraid of black replying
to that would be if this queen just sort of gets
in the position in any way if it just gets down
queen b2 queen a1 once the rook gets down here
i'm i'm very scared uh that's why i think the
evaluation bar is hovering uh very close to the
middle which which means that um not that we're
heading over as a draw robert but that this could
definitely go either way and i think it has a lot
to do with these queens being on or off the board
but let's see that's a great move queen e6 and the
point is you give up your d5 pawn which goes to
e6 black can win it but this rook c7 idea is too
powerful because if we trade black's rook slides
to e7 to win the pawn the white knight comes to d5
and the rook has to take the pawn the rook comes
to c7 you establish dominance on the queen side
and this is very common in these kind of positions
even at the cost of a pawn getting the d5 square
for your knight is so valuable yeah and that
knight is really powerful protects f4 the f4
pawn keeps every single piece out of the e5 square
it's like this f4 pawn is actually dominating the
black pieces you might might not even recognize
that it's hard to hard to tell the impact but this
pawn is huge right now for sure and look at this
from knight c hitting the queen hitting the d6
pawn the queens have to come off because the rook
and f7 needs a defender as well so i really like
this move knight c8 and i guess for lawrence you
don't want to trade queen to maybe queen f8 but
that looks like you're on your back foot while
white is making progress and i understand what
lawrence was doing he went h4 to go bishop h6 get
this f4 pawn and it couldn't be protected but wait
e7 he wants e7 rookie 6 rook c7 though and then
he's going to like move his king go bishop f6 but
it seems slow the only saving grace for black is
if this pawn somehow gets rolling if it doesn't
get picked up here then it goes d5 d4 that's true
and look at look at roberto says i'm gonna start
bishop d4 because if you move your rook i'm going
to play rook c7 and pin your bishop on g7 that's
probably just game right that looks like
a great move that looks pretty gamey
yeah it's i mean rook c7 is next i think if you're
lawrence you just have to take on e6 your opponent
doesn't have that much time left play like 95
right it's funny we had the same exact thought
here but it's because we've played enough you
know speed chess bullet chess in particular where
sometimes you just make a confusing move and play
it quickly and then your opponent doesn't have
time to work through the complications even if
they are objectively winning so if pawn takes pawn
takes now you have the f and both of the e pawns
rolling and that could spell trouble for white
yeah i know this is like probably very over
but it doesn't feel that winning for white yet
like we're very close to that level um but
i'm i'm looking at like uh knight takes d6
ideas um looks really strong um taking here and i
don't know how that end game goes but to my eyes
you something like getting the move king to f2
and g3 and you win with two pass pawns right and
actually we see our resignation and the reason why
is i guess he wouldn't take on g7 for a turn he
just pushes b-pawn first and the king wouldn't be
able to stop it so now that was really instructive
technique by roberto and honestly it's one-to-one
and it seems like the games have been dictated by
the styles of the position in game one lawrence
was a great look at this we have an italian turned
into a duboff when he beat sergey karjakin with
his crazy b4 move so this is lawrence's style
once again roberto wins with the white pieces
in his style like more closed position where
he could outplay lauren so i don't know all the
theory here i just know that dude beat karjakin
in this line and that means it must be scary yeah
and i think i think at the end of the day if if uh
duba does something like this lawrence is going to
be one of the first uh you know practitioners uh
lawrence loves this stuff anyway and i know that
feeling when you have a certain style and you see
someone emulate it at the top level you're like
wow you know this is unbelievable they're showing
how to do this against guys of world uh you know
world-class caliber uh you know i'm i want i want
some of that to uh i want that rush that feeling
and it makes sense to me that lawrence is picking
up this this opening here and i'm sure no doubt
that he knows a thing or two about this it's
quite possible he knows it a bit better than his
opponent which is already you know some type of
advantage to speak of yes because this is a very
risky variation i mean look at black's position
right now the material is even it right it doesn't
even look like it but black has six pawns white
has wait why is seven pawns now so now it's no
longer even but you can take you could take on d4
and restore the material quality but this is such
a wild looking position and that's what lawrence
is counting on it's not the objective value so
much as the practical force of this when you're
playing with under five minutes in the clock yeah
yeah it's more that uh lawrence is gonna you know
own the dark squares so to speak the knight on a5
is quite offside and there's also that element of
surprise i don't know how surprised roberto is
here but let's just say there's that element of
surprise that you feel like you're bringing the
other player into your prep or your style your
game rather than the other way around so lawrence
gets to play uh more in the style of game one
and less in the style of game two where things did
not go his way he was not able to get an attack
going speaking of styles and surprises roberto
played e5 on the first from this game i didn't
even register that but he played the keracon in
game one and now he played e5 so are we gonna see
different openings pretty much every game is that
the type of player roberto is going to be today
obviously most of these titles strong players
can play a variety of styles but i just realized
that we have a different opening and that's why
this kind of crazy position uh was able to be
reached on the board and do you think we have a
different opening because he's playing different
uh styles or because he got rocked in game one
and he's like okay let's put that carrot gun
on the back burner just for a couple games get
that confidence back maybe he's gonna look at
it in the break and then bring it back um the
car con i feel like is not an opening where
uh you have to play the same line over and over
like i think he can change that up pretty easily
but um is he gonna is he gonna amend that before
he plays it again that might be the question
yeah it's a great question and for lawrence he's
capable of playing pretty much any opening himself
so here we continue our tactical flare and this
pong went to g3 that's bad for the light squares
and guess what only black has a light square
bishop but at the same time that knight and a5
is still stuck and out of the game the king that's
castled queenside can get under fire when your
king's on opposite side of the board hey you know
if my king is safe i'm just going to go all in
against your king so right now black needs a move
the queen's under attack i would not take on d4
that feels pretty risky to allow some kind of
bishop to beat two or rook d one first and then
you should be two giving you the night for free
for free in quotes because i wouldn't yet uh but
i think you just need to move the queen
and roberto taking his time wisely oh
he takes yeah i mean so this move was just in
time knight c3 by lawrence because bishop h3
uh was about to be in the position by black now
i'm surprised by a lot of these moves because
i thought after queen d4 that we were on the same
page rook d1 and if queen takes c3 you just trade
the rooks on d8 and go bishop b2 or just bishop b2
straight away and you're picking up that free rook
on g7 as for this bishop e2 doesn't look
like a terrible move but um it does look
like maybe some chances where miss rook d1 looked
really active and quite forcing yeah this is the
difference between seeing tactics generally and
specifically lawrence understood that there's
a problem for black taking this pun on d4 he
saw his bishop going to b2 instead of sitting
behind a pawn it now has the length of diagonal
so he recognized that queen 64 he had something
he just didn't do the precise move order and now
look what roberto does say hey queen d3 don't mind
trading queens if you take me i have a past pawn
the c4 square is vacated for my knight and if you
try to keep the queens on the board where is your
queen going like are you really going to give me
control of your light square as your king is not
very safe and maybe in fact black can play move
like queen to c or d2 and go after this bishop on
b2 and the knight on c3 so there's too much going
on here i believe for white to keep the queens on
the board and that's why we just saw rook to d1
yeah and i was almost wondering about queen d3
because i thought queen d2 maybe was more forcing
to really get those queens off the
board hitting the queen and the bishop
um the reason that that tactic was missed and it's
actually kind of a big deal is that the rook on g7
it wasn't coordinated with the rook on d8 anytime
you can make a an exchange of rooks and the king
has to like take and come towards the center that
always feels like a good sign so i think roberto
has emerged with a great position lawrence is not
going to be happy playing that type of opening
and then having to just trade queens into an end
game where he's actually just one pawn down and
he could take on a5 which would leave black
with one of the ugliest pawn structures i've
ever seen with double iceland a pawns double
isolated c pawns but you have a pass pawn on
c4 and your rook even though it was a problem
piece on g7 before that rook can even slide up
via g5 or something like that so i do like black's
chances here this is the type of position roberto
could only have dreamed of considering how wild
the game was before this but as you said him
on he's up a pawn and if you start treading
pieces that extra pawn will make itself felt
yeah and you know if this uh knight reroutes to d6
i think that that would be quite good is he going
here and then taking and going rook c1 that's
actually what i thought he was gonna do
okay but i like rook g5 here i'll give
you the e6 pawn to take your b5 pawn like
that one's hanging and if you play a4 to defend
now my knight finally has an active free square
to go to with the b3 square so he plays rook d8
instead i guess he's just trying to go rook d3 and
just wants the pawn to go but can
you just take and go rookie three
i think so yes um because one thing to not
underestimate at all is a bishop against a knight
if white just has one pass pawn over here it might
compensate for like oh the entire queen side right
and oh so by the way i really like that knight b7
move because he did not want to allow the bishop
to take at that point as he's two pawns down on
the king side and now take on b5 you can't take
on c4 because rook d1 check rook c1 pinning the
bishop he overlooked it i could i could tell he
had overlooked it just by the way he was playing
but now he has officially overlooked it and rook
d1 rook c1 just wins a piece yeah and it's funny
because almost looked like he overlooked it but
now it's very clear on the webcam yeah lawrence
overlooked that oh he was just distraught he was
you know beside himself there and now roberto
is about to pick up his second game in a row and
lawrence will have to go back to the
drawing board because this opening did not
go the way he wanted it to well actually kind of
did but then he misstep by playing bishop b2 so
he he had the craziness that he was desiring but
he didn't convert it that well well the nice thing
about his position is that you just play the pawns
you don't calculate you know you're pissed off you
you blunder to peace hey at least take some
solace and just pushing these pawns blindly
you know amman it's probably too early to
think match strategy but i know roberto is
a fantastic bullet player i would consider
resigning already if i were lawrence not not
in this particular game but generally speaking
if you lose a piece sometimes you just resign
so you get more games in but there are these
three pawns here on the king side for white so
lawrence should play this particular
game out i just thinking about it
in terms of the overall match picture because
actually white's pawns are quicker right now
and it's possible that this blunder turns
into 40 because h6 how do you stop the pawns
because you have g4 to stop the rook like that
white's winning now according to the engine rook
g7 i mean basically push the pawn and decide about
the rook later yes that's that's the way i'm i'm
thinking about it and you could have played the
pawn to h7 you know rook hay check pawn h7 so
this is just wild and now there may only be
like one or two ways for roberts to hold i
think knight f5 is rook g5 happening and how do
you defend this knight right if you play rook
c5 you walked into a pin so why can't even
start pushing the h pawn some more this is
wow this is turning real fast so knight
h6 maybe just run around with your knight
yeah i guess the well oh 93 check
if you move the king and then go g4
that feels pretty logical there's going to be
a rook check but 17 seconds for roberto i think
we can easily see lawrence winning this game
which is just absolutely crazy but if he goes
h6 now rook c6 you have to i thought you'd
play rook c6 and just take the pawn directly
because the problem with this line is you
will win the h6 pawn but you're losing
white's just better yeah you lost a very important
tempo because you're dropping this pawn on
a5 i would have actually gone to g4 with the
king i know it looked like counter-intuitive
king g2 hits the rook but king g4 is
just like better place for the end game
white should probably win this like i feel
pretty good about lawrence's position here
wow what a turnaround this game has seen but
king d6 trying to go c5 look at roberto very
smartly saying i just need to push my pawns
don't play it now because the rooks get traded
rook be a great move his technique at this point
in time is perfect c5 c4 keep those pawns going
and unfortunately for white you're not in
time with your past pawns and what a tale
this has been amman where at first you blunder
a piece then your pawns are really fast all of
a sudden black is down pawn but his pawns
are faster weird stuff and i like this from
lawrence i think the goal is to just get your
king in um asap like king d4 rook c6 ideas
um just chase these guys down and then connect
your own pawns right but b3 is happening that
rook is behind the past pawns be very careful that
you don't just allow this pawn to go promote for
black this is a point it's so bizarre yeah it's b3
or c3 he has a choice and that's where it becomes
a problem you expect c3 and then b3 happens
but this is why lawrence dropped his rook back
and now how do you go okay two seconds you
gotta move roberto go oh my gosh and oh oh
oh we lost some time oh my goodness the plus one
is just just not enough and lawrence is over the
moon look at that reaction he blended a full
piece like the fullest piece you could blender
wow that was unbelievable and lawrence you could
see how much he's putting into this match at first
he was devastated that he blundered then he calmed
himself down and he realized something that even i
wasn't realizing hey wait a second my pawns are
fast i still have a chance here and he actually
wins that game and for roberto where did all
his time go uh well it went into winning a piece
and then uh not only overthinking but probably
miscalculating and totally missing the right idea
defensive idea to stop those pawns because there's
always a balance between getting your pawns going
and at some point maybe using the knight
to sacrifice for an advanced white bomb but
what he ended up doing was was like the worst of
both worlds he didn't get his pawn going quick
enough he lost one of his queen side pawns and he
didn't really stop the the h-pawn without losing
his piece so uh just a disaster game and that's
how you until i mean lawrence was ready to throw
in the towel and all of a sudden he's sitting up
in his chair and fist bumping at the end yeah and
now he's playing the bononi where his knight
on c7 looks absolutely amazing that is sarcasm
that knight does not look very good but this is a
typical plan can you get rook b8 can you play b5
i personally am not a big believer in the benoni i
think it just gives white a very healthy position
but there are times you put b5 or play f5 so it
is in lawrence's style and for me i just i don't
personally like it but it is an acceptable
opening we can use the term acceptable
yeah right it's it's fine you know it has its
merits and uh well rook v8 i think his intentions
are quite clear yep we want to play b5 and what we
see is a position where lawrence is going to have
a bit better control of the dark squares just
because you know the light square bishop has
traded for the knight on f3 at some point in this
game and uh you know black's going to go like
knight d7 wants to have the e5 square b5 at the
moment roberto saying look you know give me the a
file and get my rook down a7 um at the moment i'm
not sure lawrence wants to open the position but
that is what he wants to do in general and he's
going to go b5 right if there's any player who
wants to play aggressively it is lawrence trent he
goes b5 which is a good decision and look at this
this e4 pawn looks strong but he can quickly get
in trouble so that's why roberto put his knight to
d1 but knight to f2 and he's keeping everything i
don't want to say safe and sound but for now it's
a pretty compact situation yeah i love knight
b5 i think knight d7 some sort of knight d4
taking over some dark squares in the middle of the
board makes a lot of sense although this pawn on
e4 is defended knight f2 bishop f3 it actually
can't really advance that easily unless you want
what i was going to say unless you want to
make things completely murky and tactical
but not only does that play into the
style of number one lawrence trent
but number two the bononi as an opening is ready
for these types of skirmishes in the middle
yeah although there is a bishop pair for white
so if the position opens up those bishops can
thrive and look at this bishop f4 winning one
of the rooks but look at lawrence i don't care
about that rook look at my dark square bishop
you take me on e5 i take back but this is an
important lesson right now do i say i don't think
you should take that rook couldn't move anywhere
if you move that rook you lose the other rook so
i think that roberto had one move to use there and
by taking on e5 he helped lawrence just say i'm
gonna be in this material deficit regardless but i
now have the activity because i get to strike
and it looked like he could have used the knight
knight d3 knight g4 put more pressure on that rook
and if you could take the rook with the knight
then i think lawrence's sacrifice is simply
not good that's true and right now it's pretty
double-edged i would say that when i look at this
you have a rook for a knight in one pawn but also
this opposite-colored bishop dynamic and don't
take on c5 now because bishop d4 check but just
in general the black controls the dark squares
white doesn't really control the light squares
because the knight in excellent black kitty piece
says your d-pawn's not going anywhere your best
move for white will be bishop takes pawn on d5 you
can't do that so the bishop on f3 doesn't really
have anything to boast about yeah and there's
an interesting choice there queen takes d6
sort of speaks to getting that knight into d4 but
knight d6 the best blockader in chess supports the
c pawn push that rook can get behind and that pawn
just basically sits on c3 defended by the bishop
i love the confidence that lawrence is playing
with in this game he didn't bat an eye when he
lost that exchange i or i don't even want to say
lost that exchange when he gave up that exchange
because that's just so thematic it's exactly the
way you want to play in this opening plus if i had
to take a position i'm taking black here oh me too
and i think that lawrence is to be a bit careful
because you do want to push this pawn to c3 but
you don't want to just use all of your attention
over there right if you just get tunnel vision
that could be a problem but i like his move
queen f6 he's using his queen as bishop he has
a much better situation bishop on f3 it's not a
good piece and there's nowhere for it to go like
if i said hey come on throw the bishop somewhere
you'd say okay i'll go to c6 that looks good good
luck getting there right right and it's not that
much better but you know you can't even get there
so that's the biggest problem in white's position
is you can't use your extra material well and
in fact black with the c pawn as you pointed out
it's just uh roaming down the board yeah this and
it needs to be said like even move like queen d4
if the queens get traded it's not like roberto's
position gets that much better it might not help
at all like end games and he plays queen d4 like
he even offers the exchange takes takes rook d2
runs into bishop e3 so i think he's just going
to go to e2 but it's just an example of like you
can trade queens while being quote unquote down
material because of how strong the pieces on the
board are in black's position absolutely and when
you are ahead material like roberto is by points
you want to think about how to give some of it
back that should be in the back of your mind
so if roberto can like play uh some kind of
like rook takes c4 and give up his rook for
that knight in that pawn you would want to do
that it relieves the rest of your position so
i like how robert just handling this the last
couple of moves but he's still in trouble
yeah rook 8 played just thinking about rook a2
like rookie a2 take on v2 got two pieces there
as soon as you get that b-pawn by the way the
floodgates open like those two pawns might even
be worth sacking a piece just to get that pawn
depending on the position i was thinking about
that as well like can i play some kind
of bishop takes b2 and give up my piece
of course lawrence shouldn't do that and
by the way both players have a lot of time
when i'm looking at this position i would
expect them to be down to like 30 seconds
but they are moving very quickly and they're both
playing well in this game so if you play rook a2
i'm going to probably have to do something like
rook to b1 and how does black proceed from there
is going to be an important question and the thing
with rook d2 like if you just look at white's last
you know almost 10 moves what is he doing he's not
doing anything proactive it's all reactive and it
just means that lawrence sort of has a free hand
in this game he can choose do i want to push the
tempo now do i want to you know change the pawn
structure a bit do i want to get my king in the
middle um it seems like lawrence can just decide
how he wants to play this game um does he want
to push the tempo or play this game a little bit
longer get the clocks lower i don't see any active
plans that roberto has he's sort of just shuffling
and defending yeah i think the one move i would
consider here for roberto's bishop e4 just to kick
that rook out of b1 the knight does not want to
take on e4 so at least i kick your rook away and
then i don't have a plan exactly but i don't want
to move threat i can be happy about that yeah
that's something that's something it looks like
you know maybe pointing towards g4s of the
world uh with king h3 although i don't think
that's that's really what you want to do here no
and lawrence uh for on his end he needs to find
the correct path for it will it be c3 will it be
b3 i like the look of b3 you cement that pawn on
b2 and maybe you can go attack it but the problem
with playing b3 is that both of your pawns are on
light squares and it's not like the bishop will go
win those pawns but you have to be careful about
doing some of that because when you push the b
pawn c3 becomes a bit less powerful in many of the
variations so instead lawrence wins rook to e1 the
bishop to g2 roberto is kind of aimlessly moving
around but at least he's doing it quickly because
lawrence is now down what 40 seconds on the clock
yep he's down 40 seconds uh what i was maybe
thinking for lawrence is you know almost put the
pieces back where they just came from tried bishop
e5 f6 and then like some long king walk up to like
c5 or even to like b5 a4 b3 um basically i feel
like this king needs to participate i agree with
you and lawrence is spoiled for choice which is
why he's spending so much time look at him he is
upset he's frustrated because he knows his
position is better roberto knows the same but
he's like what do i do he trades rooks and that
simplifies things and sometimes that will allow
your plan of a king march into the center and all
that good stuff but that also means that you may
not have enough material remaining to press for
a win yeah and the good thing at the moment is
the rook is stuck to that b-pawn as soon as this
rook you know gets free and can maybe approach the
funds from behind that's a whole different game um
i don't know whether i love or hate the decision
from lawrence right now because you know f6 you
know is a little bit harder to do to run that
king the g pawn would be weak from the bishop and
right now bishop e2 is the idea to try to hit that
to c4 pawn but i think that this is still good
for for lawrence i i don't hate his decision
yeah it still looks pleasant for black but again
it does he have enough material remaining so b3
i like that move now as white was going to play
bishop e2 next and now the rook has to move away
and black will play king f6 i don't quite see
where finishing touch will happen but c3 will
be a consideration in your future and then put
my pawn on b2 and just keep you tied down so
that's what lawrence i think is going for he
does so and i'm not sure it's enough though
yeah i'm not sure it's enough i i think with that
plus one and the fact that you can just throw that
pawn on b2 and have it protected it should be
at the very least solid but what you're worried
about is white you know putting his bishop on
c2 covering that and then the rook suddenly is
free to play the rook can just do things you don't
know what those are you know how dangerous they're
going to be but for example the rook's cutting
the king off and that pawn ever starts to move
up the board it's just curtains for black that's
right and the great thing about obstacle bishops
here is that you put upon a b2 that pawn can't be
attacked the terrible thing is that the b1 square
is a light square so as we're discussing here that
you put a bishop on b1 your bishop protects your
pawn but can't actually kick that blockading piece
out so roberto's hanging on by a thread here he's
really just barely holding things together but
look at the clock it is about to be even on time
that's good news for lawrence because his
position is better and it's much harder
to defend this as white than it is to push
with black yeah you can just shuffle i mean
pawn there knight to a3 just as a simple uh way to
threaten b1 love the way that lawrence has played
this game like start to finish maybe it wasn't
perfect but that's what chess is you're not going
to know the exact winning plan lawrence was poking
and prodding around with his rook with his pieces
he's going to get this pawn to b2 and i think he's
done a fantastic job let's see if he can convert
yeah i don't like defending the b1 square with
the rook even though he's keeping his d5 pawn
there could be i was about to say bishop d2
next move bishop c1 and if the rook has to go
to b1 that rook is stuck there this reminds me
of niels grandilius against jordan van forest
when the rook gets caught like that it's just
game knight c4 knight d2 and that is game over
um so as as you just pointed out i mean that once
the knight comes in it's okay knight c4 knight a3
knight e4 knight c3 lots of ways to do it can't
even play king e2 knight d2 is a fork oh that
that's painful and what a win by lawrence trent i
mean he really played a great start to this match
with the exception of game two right game two
was not friendly to him and that's what roberto
needs to do we are taking our half-time break here
but aman what advice would you give to roberto to
try to come back in this match it's still pretty
close yeah very very close match uh three to one
he obviously had that game that slipped away from
him so in his head it probably feels in terms of
how they've played or like a two-two match because
he just slipped that game away where he was up a
piece so i don't think roberto should panic at
all he might go and check that karo khan because
we know that he does love that opening so i would
say just relax um you you know you're the stronger
player on paper rather and i don't think that
he needs to panic at all lawrence is playing
great chess but if roberto steps his game
up this match is going to be tied again in
no time for sure and speaking of relaxing
all you relax take a brief break we will
be back in just a few minutes for more of this
match between roberto molina and lauren shred
and we return with more action from this
fascinating battle between two of the strongest
ims we got and amman it has been so great thus far
lawrence thriving in those tactical positions but
also showing some classy end game technique in
that fourth game we just saw yeah i gotta give
a lot of credit to lawrence not only in this match
so far because we've seen so many different styles
from him um robert like i i feel like right off
uh the bat in game one we saw his aggressive hey
take my pawn uh poison pawn variation i'm just
gonna storm the king style and execute it very
well then in uh his other win we saw him blunder
a piece and make a comeback stay in the game he
lost his confidence and he got it right back
pushing those pawns claiming a win somehow
at the end of that and then we see this last
game where start to finish you know he stacks the
exchange plays a beautiful positional controlled
game and executes in the end game it's like oh
we're seeing everything from lauren's trent right
now we certainly are and he's been nervous we
saw his reaction when he blundered that piece but
nerves are a good thing alexander grisha said this
he said you know nerves are good it means i care
and so you like to see when players are showing
their emotion but still controlled after that fact
so lawrence three to one lead thus far for roberto
i feel like he needs to play of course like he did
in the second game but you reminded me of the fact
that he was of a piece so he had that chance to be
level at this point and it's that close of a match
right yeah so that that's the thing is that uh
roberto knows he he's basically played well enough
to earn himself at least two wins in this match
so far so he can he can tell himself that at all
times what we have here is uh lawrence actually
changing it up right he played bishop b5 one for
the rui lopez instead of bishop c4 from uh last
game we were wondering if he was maybe going to
look at that line and i wonder if he did look at
it during the break where you get a couple minutes
like well that didn't really pan out roberto
knew what he was doing let's go for something
that's a bit more closed in nature but speaking
you know as we have been about styles this would
seem at least on a high level thought that it's
good for roberto to get into these positions
yeah i wonder um if lawrence because of the
fact that he uh does a lot of commentary on
uh high-level matches like the world championship
i wonder if he sees openings like this in those
matches a world championship match candidates
and starts to implement them a bit more into his
own chess because it's almost like this main main
main line very lopez it's one of the last things
i'd expect to see lawrence trent playing yeah
especially in the blitz game it's kind of odd but
we see this in the speed chess championship when
you know you have the maxine vustrilla graves the
world playing but this is really mainline stuff
but i do like lawrence's position this knight on
b7 is really not happy where is it going from
there and roberto says yeah i'm just going to
play quickly i'll take on e7 please queen takes e7
you're freeing up the board for me and i want to
remind everybody that c4 square is looking awfully
juicy for a black knight when you have pawns two
squares away from one another look at the square
in between that c4 square is blacks for the taking
at a later point yeah and i think that explains
the move knight e3 perfectly i don't even need
to touch on that because that watch is over that
square we might even just see c4 right now in the
position it looks very reasonable i know it looks
funny all four pawns up there on the fourth rank
but c4 looks like a pretty good move and one of
the reasons i wanted to do that robert before
bishop b2 was i wanted to you know do the cheeky
rook swing get the rook into the center rook d2
rook e2 rook c2 before playing bishop b2 that
makes a lot of sense because what is that rook
doing look he just won bishop a1 probably because
of what you were saying and i think black should
have went for a strike with a5 because now after
c4 a5 doesn't look nearly as appealing there's a
lot of tension in the center that rook as you just
pointed out i'm on that can go to c2 now because
in line with the queen and go to d2 to line
up along that defile which is bound to open up
or it can even go to e2 if you need to defend that
pawn so you're right i like white's position now
lawrence is handling this well and roberto he just
feels like he's floundering a bit he doesn't have
a concrete plan and now the position is about to
open up and that bishop on a1 watch out for that
piece wow yeah that's going to be very strong
the only thing about lawrence's position is
he's kind of lost the move like bishop
b2 bishop a1 and in a lot of cases you
actually want your bishop to be on b2 just
because it controls a few more squares so
um if the rook was already in the center somewhere
and bishop on b2 i think it'd be a little bit
better but hey you can't have everything
this knight on b7 as you mentioned is still
out of the game you know almost wants to go to d8
and e6 just to play just to have some scope but uh
e4 pawn taken and all i can say is that bishop
on a1 we mention how dominant is going to be
taking on e4 looks greedy and it doesn't look like
he has the position to justify uh you know taking
the time uh to take that pawn i already see a ton
of different ideas for why queen c2 hits the rook
now you're throwing c takes b5 when the c pawn for
black cannot recapture the queen is hanging down
the file so after cb5 the c6 pawn will be white
and that's an important pawn because yes black
stole a central pawn but i'm splitting your pawns
on the queen side if i take out c6 but i can also
play knight d5 just continue pushing forward here
he takes on c6 which is good right this is a great
position for white but he could have been tactical
with knight to d5 yeah it could have just combined
them knight d5 and then queen c6 and then both
knights get in there like this knight on b7 is
still just not participating at all no and
it may have to go to d8 to just trade off or
something like that but look at this roberto gains
a tempo essentially white could have had the same
queenless position with a knight on d5 but black
gets the knight first and now black can play d5
and that knight on b7 may come to d6 and into
the c4 square that we talked about so long ago
and it's funny how that one little extra tactic
it's like the sprinkle that robert's putting on
top of the uh the cupcake because queen takes c6
is a great move but knight d5 taking advantage
of the pin would have stopped knight v6 would
have stopped d5 would have stopped knight d6 and
black's whole activation plan to get back in
this game it looks like it's it's just a product
of not putting that that little knight d5 move
in it seems to be making all the difference
it certainly does and black is now freeing up the
board for the bishop on the fade the knight on b7
and as is typical in the rolo pez if your knight
is stuck on b7 your position often is very
terrible anatoly karpov can teach everybody finger
three about that and right now lawrence plays g3
he's not happy to make that move knight d6 knight
c4 black's pieces are just going into the board
here it's like flying freely yeah i i mean the it
looks like rook d1 is also an idea to to get that
on knight c4 is he trying to say look take that
pawn i take on a3 and and then the knight on b7
is already got that d6 square it just looks like
it's getting closer and closer to it's just an
equal position yeah i agree and i do wonder why
he left his knight on b7 he was going for like
the quick pounce of like knight c4 i'm going
to threaten the a3 pawn but the knight on b7 is
still a problematic piece and even if it is level
i feel like the game was turning in black's favor
so bringing the knight out from the wayside
into the action could have been beneficial for
black not just to equalize but even to play for
more yeah i like the idea of move ago knight d6
because then if rook d1 knight c4 from the d-file
and if knight takes d5 there's always this rookie
one trick to win the piece on d5 so it's kind of
a nice way to get the c4 square but not let white
execute maybe the plan that he's going for which
is just to probably uh say look i see the the
the black pieces coming into the game let's just
equalize things and not let this get out of hand
and lauren spent some time quickly responds with
rook a2 that rook can come to a7 at some point i
don't think i would do it just yet but that's the
thing knight c3 hits the rook on e4 or the pawn
on b5 but then the pawn b4 is hanging in return
because that nine oh actually there's a knight c6
two both of them are protecting so maybe you can
play knight c3 and just go after the b5 font it's
funny there's so many like knight c7 uh knight a7
knight c3 knight d4 there's so many ways to hit
that d-pawn uh it'd almost be a shame at this
point if he didn't manage to get his hands on it
um it does look like the most likely scenario
though is both sides win the respective b-pawns
and you know from there it just sort of equalizes
but the time advantage that roberto has could be
maybe the so far that's the biggest difference
in the position both sides active pieces all
around look at the time though a minute and a half
plus yeah and there's something long-term that i
believe lawrence is struggling with the bishop on
a1 looks beautiful on the board's longest diagonal
but there's a pawn on b4 that's on a dark square
so if the knights come off the board all four of
them black's bishop can attack white's pawn and
then white's pawn has to resort to defense so
that's something to look for if you're roberto and
you're trying to figure out hey can i actually try
to squeeze this equal position into a win rookie
2 is a great start of course that's an active move
but i'm just thinking about what pieces i want to
trade and if the knights come off white is the one
who's stuck with a worse pawn yep and rook e2 uh
threatens ideas like rook d2 hey move your knight
well you're walking into knight e3 fork using that
pin on the f-pawn and you know just rook d2 other
rook down to e2 feels like roberto is making
easy fast moves and look at that time tick down
for lawrence he comes with each four i think we're
slowly seeing this tick you know in in black's
favor here as he plays h5 so now he has an escape
score for the king right and if you toss an hour
on each player's clock it still is a difficult
position to figure out but you see lords in 18
seconds he is two minutes behind on the clock so
if i'm roberto i'm just keeping things a bit sharp
knight f5 threatens 93 check and it's not about
going for one move tactics it's just putting your
opponent in as difficult spot as possible that
could be with a simple move but sometimes you
have to be aggressive 94 hits the f2 pawn how do
you even defend that bishop comes d4 mind because
the bishop on a1 is just not a good piece anyway
as you pointed out so at least we can centralize
that the rook t8 move is not possible those
knights actually do control a fair few amount of
squares rook c8 to hit the knight just blunders
everything away with 97 check now good call 97
check is something that white can rely on and i
would probably play my knight from c4 to d6 and
over to f5 and that's mainly because of the time
situation but that bishop on d4 is defending f2 if
i can somehow get that piece off the board then
the white king and in particular pawn f2 get in
danger so i think knight c to d6 makes some sense
but maybe i'm overlooking some kind of counter
for white but 10 seconds that's what i'm really
looking at exactly um as white like as lawrence i
am moving that king sometime soon you know king
f1 king g1 i just have to get out of the way
the rooks are forked the rooks are forked there's
no way out of this he walks right into a fork
well he thought he was it's one of those
things you think you're hitting the knight
and oh my goodness he's totally he's totally
botched this one again we see roberto right
at the end of the game when he seems like it's
trending in his favor he's messing things up and
he can't even play g6 here to protect the h5 punk
because rook a rook h8 checkmate that bishop on d4
it's been the best piece it thrives right now so
roberto is down a rook for a knight and one point
it's very confusing lawrence has 6.5 seconds
left so i would probably play rook d6 here
pin that bishop and then lawrence figure out
wait do i need to protect my work on d1 or
just leave this here what do i do and you
guys rook to a1 and oh that's a good move
very very good move and a practical choice of
that love that by uh by lawrence just the the
the understanding that oh young peace young people
protect that my goodness yeah i can't get around
complimenting people i'm gonna stop that you
know as soon as you went to compliment him he
drops the piece but the position was complicated
look at how many minor pieces were concentrated
in a very few amount of squares so rook a7
i like that you're trying to take f7 you
are down material it's two pieces against a rook
knight of four check where's that king going e7
okay king if you're a king six knight of four
back king six i take the g7 pawn as well oh wow
yeah that's even worse so you have to go back to
g6 i guess i think he's got his like pseudo draw
here unless he wants to give the f7 pawn really
go for it he's not happy maybe rook takes f4 just
sacrifice your rook bishop c3 pawn b4 there
he goes energy there he goes i don't like
f6 though whoa rook b7 was needed there yes
rook takes d2 oh my gosh blunders galore here
oh that's a hole no that can't be good this
is just the nervousness the time trouble yeah
black might win this game still like black's king
could try to kick that rook out of there but look
at lawrence in time to bring his king around oh my
gosh just in time for c4 oh not f3 get king g3 oh
there goes the g6 pawn this is and there
are kings cut off as well yeah this is good
this isn't good king of the board king e3 i
would cut that king off king d3 i like that
and you can't play c2 too soon now you were
threatening z2 but because the pawns promotion
rook g6 is needed maybe uh but the pawn is going
to have f4 no this looks like it should be a draw
if black establishes that pawn on the
dark square and the bishop defends both
it feels like we're heading toward the
draw but this game can last forever
he's going to build up some time which
is absolutely the way to do things
um the question really is after he has all that
time what can you do with it and i'm not sure
that i know yeah the answer is he has time but
his pieces don't have freedom here so like he's
just stuck like he king can't go over the king's
side because the c pawn is free otherwise the
rook has to go defend and draw by repetition makes
sense and i don't i don't think in this particular
position at the end that either player is going
to be too upset with that result but i think
both players should be upset with that result
in general both players had had opportunities
to win that game at various points and it wasn't
just like they each had one chance no they each
had multiple chances that's very true and look
at lawrence he's playing b6 bishop b7 you know
he's trying to hit at white center but this is
already a roberto opening the other pawn triangle
now he pushed up on e4 very solid here so i like
this for roberto compared to the bononi even if i
personally don't like the binoni i think that it
suits lawrence and roberto struggled with it a bit
yep and there's no no shame in admitting
that especially in a match you don't have to
don't have to put any uh any ego there just play
the openings that that seem to be benefiting you
um it doesn't matter their reputation knight h5
and lawrence is he's got that bishop that never
looks too great against uh you know pawn
chain like that and the question is always
am i going to reroute that bishop or am i going to
leave it there pressuring that pawn just go for f5
and then put the pressure on the d-pawn and the e4
pawn to loosen up that punch chain right this is
thematic and you would prefer that your piece had
a little bit more space for black but that's why
the move f5 is so powerful you're trying to crash
through in the center you're trying to give your
pieces more space one of the knights maybe the d
knight comes over to f6 but either way roberto is
struggling to come up with a move he has plenty
of time the game has just started but amman when
i look at this position i think okay do i want
to take on f5 but then g takes f5 there could
be e4 maybe i'm walking into a pawn storm that
might not be so good but if i leave the tension
in the center at some point is black just going
to collapse it with f takes e and knight to f6
and the d5 pawn is weak i don't really want to
play pawn to c4 but that is what he just chose
i wanted the c4 square for my knight
that's really the essence of it
yeah and i think f4 makes makes a lot of
sense here now in a position like this
i'm a little bit more concerned about stuff
like taking on f5 like knight h4 um and putting
pressure on f5 and also of course queen uncovering
the attack on the h5 knight so knight f1 played f4
still looks good especially the knight were not
on d7 f4 would look great so uh lawrence takes
and goes knight f6 but the bishop on e4 isn't that
important of a piece you can retreat it of course
but you know it it's weird because you've thrown
a fiance pawn structure but i feel like you want
to just blockade the squares like knight d2 if it
didn't block your bishop would have been a good
move just so you can keep blocking that e4 square
and knight f3 to d2 that was so i wouldn't walk
into pins and bishop g4 seems annoying like that's
a nasty pin there's there's no h3 to kick it out
bishop g4 seems like a great start especially with
that rook on on f8 um that's that looks good but
the question is after knight e3 bishop takes queen
takes you you're looking at that rook bearing down
on the queen on c uh on f3 but there's not
really any good squares to put your knight
yeah it's so annoying when it happens like
what i just lined everything up perfectly
and yeah i can't take advantage of it and that's a
really good point and you also don't want to allow
white to blockade the e4 square if that knight on
f3 just could go diagonally for a turn to go to e4
now your bishop on g7 is stuck that doesn't
look great so e4 is thematic i'm not sure if
it's good because you drop a pawn by making
play e4 but that's that's kind of thing i'm
looking at just to free up black's pieces right
and knight g for a totally different approach
but the exact same goal which is basically put
pressure on f2 that's what e4 was all about as
well e4 maybe knight g4 was to follow now we see
knight g4 first and the idea of like maybe queen
f6 next sometimes there's even sacrifices on f2
followed by like bishop g4 things to get really
really spicy here um you know pawn sacks and p
sacks galore in in the position here so i think
that this is just getting towards the position
that lawrence is turning into a tactical struggle
yeah i would play bishop g5 for white and then
play knight f1 to d2 and try as best as i can to
get my knight to e4 because i know if my knight
gets to e4 f2 is safer i'm also attacking this
d6 pawn so that's what i'd be looking for if i
were roberto and it's about even on the clock
both sides playing deliberately clear plans i
like the way this game has gone for black but
i'm worried about the long term the strategic risk
that is inherent to this kind of position and it's
that pawn on d6 the backward pawn and knight
on e4 blockades the center and threatens it
yeah knight on e4 as you just brought up is a
great piece um that just controls everything so
i just i like the flow of your bishop g5 knight
f1 to d2 and then if the bishop gets attacked it
can always come back to e3 and white's not that
concerned about losing that bishop you know go
ahead and take me i might even play tigs on
e3 slide the pieces over to the open f file
and remember trades here are not only good for the
position but they're good for roberto as a player
he seems to be doing well when he can take
things to an end game more positional struggle
and really take it to lawrence and that's why i
think lawrence it's in his style to play a move
like e5 to e4 at some point even if it gives up a
pawn the bishop slicing through the board from g7
that could be really helpful to the attacking
chances and you have to time it well you can't
just do it hey it looks good no it has to really
work i think that roberto he needs to move because
he plays knight f what's rook f takes up two oh
my god that's that's like didn't he think for
like two minutes on that move and lawrence is like
sitting back in his chair like did he just do what
i thought he just did he has no idea what's going
on and look at roberto's face he hasn't flinched
but well that's because lawrence could be looking
at the camera you know he can't can't let your
opponent know that you just completely
blundered the only intention of knight g4
i will say and maybe this is just trying to
justify a big blunder is that if you can play 94
and you don't get checkmated the 94 is really
powerful and sometimes is worth the cost of a
pawn you mentioned how with the f file open
you can slide your pieces of the f file
that still holds true like white's next move the
rook goes back to f7 it could be knight to e3
will trade knights you know all of a
sudden white's pieces are doing better
so it costs you material but you feel like
you have a healthier position remaining it
still is a pawn though so so let me get
this straight robert you're saying that
roberto molina found a way to open the f-file
without trading pieces do i hear you right
i'm just saying that i'm just trying to justify
it it was a blunder like it is i yes the rook on
f8 the 9g4 were clearly hitting this pawn f2 so
i'm trying my best here i'm on i'm trying my best
well i mean i'm not going to hate on that knight
on e4 that's exactly where i wanted it hopefully
with all the pawns intact but roberto's gonna
make the best of it and uh knight e3 is looking at
three more pieces get them off the board the queen
on f8 guards the pawn on d6 and i think roberto's
just giving his head that shake of like okay
that was a terrible blender that i just did but
at the same time we can we can work with this
you know this is not is not over it's far from
over because the extra pawn on e5 normally
when you have extra material and if pieces
get traded you want to have a past pawn it's not
that easy to push that pawn so roberto's position
is worse there's no denying that but if the queens
come off now like how is black going to win this
game that sort of the burden is on lawrence
to prove that he can win his position is great
no denying yes but maybe roberto has some chances
definitely if that knight was on e4 i mean i think
that maybe more than chances i think it was
actually really good that lawrence played the
move knight f2 which sort of went unnoticed but it
traded away the knight on e4 and uh it means that
the knight on e3 just is not attacking the d6 pawn
while blockading as well it's a good piece but i
think that was actually really smart by lawrence
yeah he's playing this part perfectly look at this
bishop on h3 there's no rook f1 for you the knight
and f6 there's nothing coming to e4 and now knight
g4 is an idea for black saying let's trade off the
knights get my bishop of g4 i'll use the f-file
not just to say hey my rook looks good but to even
attack bishop h6 is another move for black we've
been talking about a bishop staring into its own
pieces why not trade it for that good knight on e3
yeah and knight g4 immediately not only does
it prevent g4 but i mean this looks fantastic
i i like the move e4 by black getting the pieces
out maybe just taking advantage of the open file
bishop d4 bishop takes b2 i think rookie 8
if you take it obviously like this is just
all flowing beautifully and rook f1 is a necessary
move because if the trade happens b2 hangs but
so does e4 at least white has some chances it's
only one pawn that's an important pawn and black
is going to play with a free hand but the material
if it starts trading off there could be chances to
hold so look at this move look at it i like that
it's just beautiful yes really really well played
the clock all of a sudden robert's gone to 18
seconds and lawrence has it over a minute and a
half and remember last game where was lawrence
in time trouble and then roberto went rookie
six and then dropped in exchange at that moment
lawrence is keeping up the pressure look at this
bishop d4 please take me help my pawns push
forward here lawrence is really in good shape
right now he is and and bishop d4 is one of those
moves that is not what you want to see when you
have 18 seconds ticking down no your pieces are
frozen right you know you don't want to take but
you also don't want to move the bishop because the
b2 pawn is hanging so you're just stuck in place
yeah he needs moves he's i don't
even see moves at some point
bishop d1 is a good move all things considered
because if we trade bishops then my king just
comes to e2 and once again i'm going to ask that
question is how does black make progress you have
an extra e pawn but i can blockade it with my
king and where are you going from there right
yeah bishop the the light squared bishops are
actually the ones you sort of want on the board
as black based on you know the c4 pawn
and the d5 pawn if you were to trade on c3
and keep those bishops you would have pretty good
chances in the enemies you're gonna go like bishop
g2 no okay he is going to trade yeah and
well i'm serious though where two from here
i'm trying to figure out how black does this
mean rook e5 pawn b5 but you can't move your
rook off the e file without dropping this
pawn e4 so even if you try to break open
the position there are some drawbacks that are
very clear so how does black make progress here
hmm yeah maybe like king g7 g5 king g6 uh kind of
stuff you should take c4 bishop 64 was a free pawn
dude you played e3 there oh my god yes and okay
he's going rook f2 check and he still has some
chins but black could lose this game a timely rook
e6 will win the d6 pawn and i cannot tell you how
many times this has happened to me oh i'm playing
really well i'm up a pawn i get to an end game
i'm up a pawn trading down is good but you lose
the d6 one and also lawrence now at 15 seconds
roberto has four seconds remaining
and lawrence is having a struggle here
yep okay just go right back to e4 next and then
rookie six just start pre-moving here comes oh
white can easily win this game rookie six and
this is scary no it is really scary play rook e6
oh but there's then you can take the pawn yeah the
h4 pawn and then e2 like a sacrifice at some point
is just trying to promote the d-pawn for
g4 richard d7 virtue d7 just push the pawn
oh wow that's amazing that's why king c4 i
think the king could start running up the
board here yeah i think so he's gonna realize that
right now here it comes here it comes watch out
king d5 i think white's
winning yeah for sure winning
rook d4 i don't know d7 d7 and then rook d4
doesn't work and now the c pawn runs hang on yeah
wait what just happened ricky two doesn't
work yeah i was trying to go over d2 too i
was like wait but no this is winning for white
all of a sudden this is completely winning now
a whirlwind by the way if this rook were behind
the pawn which is where it typically wants to be
black would have been able to push those pawns so
because it was on the second rank it covered both
wow and the same thing that happened to roberto
just happened to lawrence right which is
completely winning you have the upper hand it was
a piece earlier now it was only a pawn but it was
a pawn plus everything that comes with it so this
was you know definitely at the same level of the
previous advantage that roberto had and messed
up so lawrence has just experienced everything
every emotion in in this match robert and he is
leading this match still and we're getting back
to the game one position but roberto looked at
this you can tell roberto quickly changed his
move order and now he stretches e5 and it's up
to lawrence to justify his pawn sacrifice he has
plenty of life in this position all of his minor
pieces look at them in the center you can castle
going in the f-file but you are down upon so we'll
store that for just a second and what i want to
say quickly that even though lawrence is up a
point in this match he may not feel that way he
just lost the game where he was up a pawn a clean
pawn where he was out playing his opponent so he
probably is feeling a bit down on himself as most
chess players do when they fail to convert and not
just that they end up losing a game they have no
business losing and can we talk about how wildly
different roberto's position is you remember the
first time they played this line it was a closed
position there was a king on g3 now it's like hang
on knight takes e3 that's the most important piece
on the board for white and black just castles and
puts a knight on e5 i mean what's going on here
lawrence's position looks very bad to me and it's
gonna be needed to be tactically justified i think
right and that's why knight d to b5 was played and
i'm trying to figure out like should i take that
knight or should i just drop my queen to e7 he
drops queen e7 and the biggest difference is like
the flow of white's pieces with these two knights
on c3 and b5 even though white keeps the material
you can't jump around with your other pieces quite
as well so that's a very interesting moment there
by uh roberto to just play queen e7 you're already
up some material the bishop on e3 is under attack
i can take the knight on b5 next turn let me
just make sure i'm not getting checking queen e5
queen e5 hits h2 and c3 what move is knight
a7 this move is absolutely wild to me
i this it's like a form of tilt almost yeah knight
takes a7 is just ludicrous like the knight isn't
attacking anything it's now trapped the the threat
is knight takes e3 what blacks about to castle
white's position is just shambles bishop takes
c3 knight takes e3 they're both hanging by some
you know but some way or another black's gonna win
huge and that's why lawrence is saying all right
look we're we're just going all in get to get the
bankroll out we're going knight d5 yeah but if
politics queen takes e3 is checked so you steal a
bishop and trade the queens you would not be able
to take on e3 of the king run h1 because rookie
one ideas with a pin so i think lauren's gonna try
nice c8 here just to uh say i'm losing a piece
regardless let me keep on having some fun but
after knight c8 there could be queen c7 something
like that to threaten mate on h2 and get the queen
out of trouble but then there's bishop f4 so
you have to be careful still if you're roberto
yeah i'm just trying to think of the material
because if you go knight c queen c7 bishop f4
you just take on c8 and castle um and you're gonna
be up a piece you know what's funny is i wasn't
actually visual even though i said knight c8 i
wasn't visualizing the knight being on c8 so i was
like oh what do i do after bishop f4 well we take
c8 is a free beast there so yeah that's a good
call oh man he does yeah so of course he is in a
plane a c8 he's not happy about it um and roberto
is just i mean he's got four and a half minutes
it's a five minute game this might actually end
so quick we get another five minute game which
is crazy uh it's two and a half minutes ticking
down on the match clock but we might actually get
another one because this is so bad for lawrence
already question for you if you're lawrence and
let's say you lose this game because it looks
losing do you just waste the rest of your time do
you essentially let your time run until the five
plus one segment is over with and then take your
break and try to refresh yourself i i think yes
um just because of how the last two games have
gone i don't think he's in the right headspace
to play more five-minute games and i think it
just could be like more of a surge for uh roberto
especially because you know he's about to get
the white pieces as well i agree so queen takes
c8 here you're up a full piece you can just castle
to safety and castle looks good yeah blacks up a
minor piece for no compensation whatsoever but
i think lawrence is just playing this out of
the system that's what i believe he's doing at
this point i'm dead lost i don't even have the
chances i did in the previous games when i was
losing i'm just going to play some moves and
just try to forget it and if he wins it he's going
to be he's going to be absolutely animated i can't
can't wait to see that kind of lawrence because we
saw how he was after he won the game down a piece
so imagine if he wins this this is totally over
this is roberto's game and roberto needs this win
to tie this match up at three and a half so this
is just absolutely crucial he can't mess this up
yeah things started getting away from lawrence in
the draw when it was three to one we had a break
we got back lawrence was in time trouble it felt
like he didn't quite feel at home in this opening
where we were saying that's a what are we in the
super grand master classical tournament with that
white side of the lopez and he got a good position
but it was complicated he was burning clock so
lawrence needs to find the opening weapons
that suit him i do believe that this opening
can be good for him it wasn't game one but
roberto studied it and then said okay i'll
handle it in a more tactical manner myself
and i'm not material yeah knight e4 here looks
like knight e4 the reason it looks so
good is that it trades every single piece
so bishop on b3 is being hit by the knight right
now then knight e4 hits the bishop on e5 and it
just means that everything disappears from the
board which is usually the easiest way to win the
game when you're off material yeah knight takes
b3 94 bishop takes c5 rookie eight you you're up
a full piece and there's no attack because none of
white's pieces remain so roberto he's got this one
he's just spending his time and he does in fact
play knight to e4 yep and we'll just see trades um
more trades i might i would probably like take
on b3 and just go maybe like f5 or something
yeah or take and play rook e6 and take this pawn
on dc oh knight c3 is a tactic coming up just
right the full force and time is officially up
so knight c3 will win the game right now or f5
rookie 6 any of them but the time it is up so we
will actually be ending the five minute portion
after this and it looks like it's going to be tied
up wow and roberto he hasn't been to like a motive
there but he just responded with like a like
grabbed his face like i'm glad i just even the
score up because this has been a true battle and
aman i gotta ask you before we go to break what
are your thoughts as we head into the three plus
one what does each side need to continue doing
and what does each player need to do differently
well roberto needs to keep playing that character
because now it's up to lawrence to say uh okay
you know the first game might have been great but
this game was just unacceptable this was just wild
terrible roberto clearly looked at this and that
paid off so just those small fixes in the breaks
that roberto is doing are clearly working for him
lawrence needs to get back to what worked for him
in the beginning part right before we took her
half time break lawrence has been playing really
good chess and i hope that he just doesn't forget
that um he doesn't think that oh uh this is going
terribly for me i'm playing poorly and then maybe
start playing out of tilt with different openings
quicker openings i think he needs to maintain the
fact that this guy's higher rated than me but
i am sticking with him and going toe-to-toe and
i can play chess at his level i think there's
a great point that the results may be tricky
to deal with because while he's lost a couple
games here his play overall has been exceptional
so you're right him on he needs to remember
that there were good times in recent past
let them continue on we will take a quick
break in return we'll get right back to this
matchup in a short time patrol in the i'm not a gm
speeches championship brought to you by chess.com
well if you can't stick around all day on your
computer watching amman and i commentate this
match you know go on the go download the app
play some good chess play your friends have a
great time and it's just it's free and you'll have
a good time playing so amman as we get back to the
over-the-board action we have lawrence we have
roberto we have three and a half points per side
who's gonna win this one my goodness i
mean this this is uh i think you and i
were hinting at it before the match um on and
off stream that this was maybe gonna be one
of the closest matches one of the hardest
to call i was looking at the chat the the
prediction poll for the five minute portion
was roberto to win or lawrence to win or draw
and it was 51 to 49 it's like literally at the
closest i've ever seen the chatpole uh you know
for those channel point uh degenerates
and what we see here is a tied match
going into the three minute portion um what i
see is that if the tilt and the the effect of
the last couple games starts to affect lawrence in
what i can only imagine should be a negative way
um if it starts to affect him at all i think
it will be negative and i think that spells
disaster for him as roberto seems to have had
a shaky start but he's just starting to warm
up and i know firsthand you know how tricky he can
be in the bullet portion lawrence is going to be
very competitive in bullet but i think roberto
just has that that extra oomph that upper hand
in bullets so i'm concerned that if things trend
in that direction the bullet portion is going to
favor him it's more about whether lawrence can
get back to what was working at the beginning
that's a fair point and the way i see this match
i feel like i haven't found either player separate
themselves because one game lawrence is down to 20
seconds the next game roberto's down to 20 seconds
and sometimes you see a trend of one player is
just getting time trouble and that will never be
good for them but it's in a back and forth battle
of through and through and right now we see the
center locked up this bishop on c8 is starting
there it hasn't gone to b7 and the previous game
lawrence had to bring the bishop back he did a
great job doing so but this could save him a tempo
yeah it's kind of interesting because there's a
line with h3 bishop d3 and this pawn is on b7 so
i don't know whether it matters but there's a
there's a move pawn b6 which is there for free
yeah and that could be a bad thing though
because the white knight can go to d4 and into c6
uh right now knight d4 is tempting me but i'm sure
there are tactics all across this board here black
is threatening to go b4 the b5 pawn is hanging you
could take that but opening the b file will allow
the b2 pawn to feel quite loose so instead roberto
just plays a3 the comma is moving the position
and i think this is still theory more or less i
think it's a6 knight d4 bishop b7 um is sort of
how things go here but um this is again an opening
that worked well for lawrence when he used it last
so it makes sense that he's going back to this
yeah i actually find white's position to be much
harder to play at this point because what's your
actual plan if i give white another turn what are
you gonna do there could be some e5 tactics we saw
roberto rely on that in a previous game where we
make this move e5 and break open the position that
was different because that was a more defensive
plan here e5 well right now you tend to be long
enough oh i wanted to play e5 so badly yeah
in that position it makes a lot of sense as well
because if the bishop's on b7 okay e5 makes maybe
less sense there's rook d8 and the d5 pawn is
being hit but what we see here is actually kind
of surprising i feel like they don't go together
bishop d7 and a6 i feel like if you're playing
bishop d7 where's a5 where's b4 if you're playing
aggressively that's the way to go but neither side
is trying to push forward at this point as you
just said a6 bishop d7 those don't go hand in hand
and if you're playing bishop d4 rookie one all
this stuff don't you usually play e5 so i think
he's now considering it and there it is you could
tell by the fact that he spent 20 plus seconds and
now he's breaking free and i like white's position
um so i would have given a real thought to the
move uh bishop takes e5 uh and followed up
with queen d4 that that puts like a lot of
pressure on g7 also hits the knights oh wow okay
that's just such a weird move leaving the knight
hanging like that i mean i get that the the knight
is loose but it makes me think of like knight
takes f7 like what's going on here knight digit 7
should just be a good move you win a pawn roberto
plays it and look at lawrence he did not at all
see that move he just shakes his head in disbelief
and you mentioned tilt starting to feel like we're
getting tilt yeah this is so uncharacteristic
um what i'm seeing here because this is just
falling apart here this is completely busted
yeah you just drop a pawn f7 that's such
an important pawn if you drop the h7 pawn
and put a pawn back on f7 your king feels
safe maybe you can fight back in the game
like roberto did when he was down a pawn
here the king is open there's still chances
for black of course that bishop on g7 remains
a monster the pawn on d5 is an isolated pawn
it's a pass pawn but if you can attack it then
you may be able to win it so roberto has his
work cut out for him he is up a pawn here and
he needs to figure out the right path forward
yeah and i mean trades obviously if uh if things
simplify too much maybe he has a chance in the
end game and we can sort of say hey that's a more
active king but it's a long way to go before we
get that and d6 might indicate ideas like rook
e7 getting that pawn even further up the board
bishop f8 played and man lawrence is just grasping
at straws because he can't even take this pawn
on d6 yet no you cannot and i would love
to get my queen to d5 or something like
that but your knights there and i think that
lawrence needs to put his bishop on c6 and i
think he'll make that move now but the problem
with playing bishop c6 at least psychologically
is you allow d7 d7 is covered for the moment but
you need to blockade the piece and hey he's one
move away from playing knight to d7 the problem
with that being where are the pieces defending
your king again so if you bring your knight to the
center of the board your king is not very happy
no it's a good point because um i wanted to also
give some credit to roberto for this move rook d1
um there's nothing that blackrook can do in the
e-file the white rook however supports the pawn
uh ready to push it forward even further queen f4
is now possible uh going towards the king side i
think that he's doing very very well here he is
and i think he needs just another avenue of attack
and g4 threatening g5 it's too obvious and you
risk your own king safety so you need to find a
way to make inroads in another manner i'm looking
to at some point with my knight on e4 so maybe
pawn f3 but that also has some risk to it because
you start pushing the pawns in front of your king
it feels a little less safe a little bit
loose a little bit loose you know as soon
as you start thinking about g4 and trying to
go g5 taking advantage of the pin you just
tell yourself ah you know it's playing g4 that's
kind of a weakness and you think twice about it
and he plays knight d5 he's just saying
i am going for the kill immediately
and the rook is uh immune from capture
the knight is pinned of course and f6
king g8 the rook will just slide back that's all
good and fun the one thing that i'm looking at
long term is this bishop on g7 and that pawn
on b2 if you don't see that when this knight
moves exactly to d7 and for some reason you forget
maybe that bishop can go ahead and steal that pawn
and that's why bishop d4 was played yeah bishop
d4 is unfortunately so strong um this queen queen
takes d6 bishop takes okay so yeah this is just
this should be fine yeah you're trying to like
come up with counter play here for lawrence you
are about even the clock under 30 seconds it will
be a bullet game and what you would ideally have
is the bishop one g7 traded for the bishop on c2
not when and the queen's off the board because the
knight is blockading on a light square you don't
want to see a light square bishop come attack
your knight later so he just doesn't have any
guard for his king and i expect that there will
be a checkmate in the near future the bishop can
come to e4 and into d5 if you're not careful oh
g4 now just great there's the g4 move played with
confidence and uh now g6 is weak as soon as h6
happens you know you you start looking at the g6
pawn as a potential target right and well i don't
like bishop before walking into a pin so rook e2
maybe rookie three but rook d7 down goes the
d6 pawn wow and you don't take and rook d2
i think black might win this game
believe it or not definitely definitely
okay so rookie six good move hitting the knight
in the a6 and the h6 pawns you can oh look at that
move roberto has been so sharp with the pins today
that was just great awareness and now black can't
move yeah it's just stuck rook d7 h4 f4 yes we
can't go rook d3 the bishop covers the square so
good on lawrence trying to get those pawns though
but that king might get mated there might be
a mate against the king of six somehow
yeah it's so hard to to orchestrate but
you're thinking about it you are and well
here goes the c pawn but take on h6 is the
h p promoting with mate what is happening here now
there's some knight moves c2 take it and then take
one d5 yeah that was a blunder c2 is just not
it you know if wait this is actually a really
tricky move knight b4 maybe okay or take on g5
first maybe and then knight before you're right
roxy seven king d6 yeah he's just gonna take it oh
my gosh what the hell is going on i don't know and
there's three pawns going for two king of four
and then king e3 oh and then you take off seven
what is happening i don't know okay we're going to
see a draw oh my god oh my gosh what happened here
we're laughing because we have we can't wrap
our heads around all of these moves that were
played and it wasn't say things that fast
no oh and who is more upset about that game
uh that's a good question i think i think roberto
for sure um i think roberto for sure just because
he he was winning like even after he maybe
messed things up he still played so well like
he got that pin in as you mentioned that was
key yeah he's been very alert for those pins
the game where he went up a piece earlier and
then even lost that game uh he he's been seeing
that very well and lawrence you could tell during
that game he did not see knight takes up seven so
tactically it feels like lawrence is not in
his finest form these last bunch of games
but that is where he really makes his mark so
we'll see how this game goes it's a caricon it's a
more closed position and that to my eyes benefits
roberto yeah this is not um something we've seen
before because the last time we saw the caracon
of course it was that poison pond variation
right and here black can keep this queen
on b6 play knight d7 at some point consider
f6 a thematic break but this is roberto style
come on lawrence let's go to the end game buddy
i will outplay you we have all eight pawns on the
board and lawrence is a fantastic endgame player
it's just not what he enjoys playing so
that's why he dropped his queen back to d1
yep absolutely queen a6 uh still on a good
diagonal so it's not like black you know misplaced
his pieces to offer that trade if black ever goes
for c5 knight c6 to put some pressure there might
be time for just knight a3 knight b5 which is
a really really good square for white hitting
d6 hitting c7 and well actually c5 has been played
and i would play knight a3 in a heartbeat and here
it comes the knights come right to b5 and you
can technically castle queen set i would not it
oh obviously i would not advise that but he
says what do you know i am going to castle
and perhaps white can't actually attack that
black king well there you go castle king b8 i am
not too impressed by this queen on a6 i feel like
you got to get rid of that knight like knight a7
or something 97 would be good right now and bishop
e7 a bit slow but white can go for f5 you have so
much more space in this position from lawrence's
perspective and so i would have played f5 and
this is why i would have played f5 first because
now if you play f5 good luck to your king on g1
maybe it escapes perhaps it's fine but that's not
what you want to open up the king side when your
king is the only one there yep so h5 do you play
g5 as white here that's the question because g5
of course the f5 square is gone but the g6 pawn
is weak and kind of a decision you have to make
if you play g takes h5 at some point you have
the better structure maybe for an end game but
we're far from the end game we're very far from
the end game and i did not like that choice by
roberto because this is thematic if someone takes
on d4 you want a knight on d4 poking at this
e6 pawn so look at this you trade away black's
defensive knight and now that knight on b5 you
said it's going to be a pain it remains so what
are you going to do about that night long term
very strong piece i mean there's definitely
just gh5 rook h5 to be considered here i i would
probably play that honestly because the queen is
so offside on a6 that i say look you can play rook
d to g8 check i'll go king f3 or king
f2 with my rook on h5 and i i think
i'm covering everything there yeah it's one
of those decisions where as a commentator i
completely agree with you and i know if i
was playing the game i would never do it
you know it's too risky can't go for that
but you're right there was a possibility
and here i don't like the fact that the pawn is
on b4 because your c3 pawn looks a bit in trouble
the rook c8 rooks c4 i'm gonna use the square in
front of that backward pawn that's often what you
want to do so i do think that black has plenty of
play against this king because it's on g2 so now
if you take on h5 roberto of course will take back
open up a check that king is in trouble yeah and
he might be relying on like rook c896 stopping uh
rook c4 but it just opens up the floodgates for
uh queen e2 check and everything everything falls
like as soon as that knight moves uh it's it's big
trouble but queen b6 is like totally different
than i thought not what i expected at all this
is falling apart for black yeah the e6 pawn is
hanging knight c6 check is 14 and now rook b1
should just win all right a5 first one
of these moves just to go for it and so
b6 for sure or sorry knight c5 rook b5 rook c8
could happen wow that's like barely hanging on
there but he's going to rely on b6 and try to
keep that pawn stuck the problem is normally you
plant your king in front of pawn it would be an
umbrella pawn your king feels safe with the pawn
on v6 but not when the knight's coming
right back to b5 and into the d6 square
knight b5 d6 is nasty um i would almost start
with that yeah i i would feel like starting with
that makes sense although can i take an a5 now
because if you go knight d6 check my king is a c6
it looks scary but you take my rook
i take yours that's a fair trade
yeah that's pretty that's pretty nice knight
d6 king c6 oh and i read lawrence's lips there
he was not happy that b takes a5 he
missed it he didn't see it coming
no doubt he was just noticing that it uh
completely foiled his plans and if you go rook
b7 or something aggressive rook b8 the knights
guarding that square it's super frustrating and
this is what's happening right we're going to
trade rooks the black knight can go to c5 where
it covers the e6 pawn and the a6 square then
that pawn on c3 is a bit loose so i think that
roberto has the upper hand maybe we run
the the king here is that the way to go
looks pretty good but perhaps we're back to saying
i'm too quick myself i'm going to win your c3 pawn
and my d-pawn can start running
or is that good enough though
as as white you play rook a6 check and you don't
calculate rook takes b6 like if you can't trade
the rooks i don't agree with the check because
it feels like i'm sort of handing the move over
but uh white's playing rook c8 roxie you win
a piece i was about to say brook seed is mate
but now worksafe's no longer meet but the knight
can't be defended lawrence lawrence is so animated
whenever whenever that happens i just look
over at the cam yeah he's shaking his hand
he's like i got the hot hand now but that was
the first time i saw roberto react and he was
look at him he's still shaking his head he can't
get over the fact that he just blundered that
completely because there's been so many examples
of that in this match piece up totally winning and
it just flips in a single move that's crazy he's
gonna resign that and roberto and look at lawrence
triumphant there but roberto did not play his
best game i think we should be clear about that he
is a fantastic player but he just didn't find the
way to coordinate his pieces well and he made some
decisions that end up being very questionable like
you know taking on d4 at first and then giving
lawrence free attack on the queen side but then he
found the right moves in critical moments he took
on a5 he got his king to c6 rook to b8 and he was
turning it around and so you kind of forget about
how bad your position was and you remember wait i
was playing for the win and then two moves later i
lose a piece no that's a that's a good point but i
think overall he would be the first to agree with
you that that wasn't start to finish the best
game that he's put together this match um and
lawrence is i mean he's taking his chances man
when he gets an opportunity he takes it um he's
not really missing these these free pieces it's
more that like sometimes we get positions where
he wins that piece and then can't convert after
that but luckily in this game or that last game
we just saw it was too easy after winning that
piece so he does take that point and take the lead
in this match again five to four and a good start
to the three-minute section for lawrence and this
has been a very high level match i'm impressed
by both players to this point and lawrence is a
point ahead he's in great shape and right now in
this position that knight on h3 it's such a thorn
in white side it looks trapped it has nowhere to
go but you can't attack it and the bishop on c8
it returns to a starting square it defends it
and you have to watch out for tactics involving
pawn f5 temporarily giving up that knight for
the attack i like lawrence's position bishop g4
to start with might be first and then f5 yeah
bishop g4 looks like a nice move because you
can almost ignore it like bishop g4 b4 it's like
okay f5 maybe like you can almost just run brent
forward with the pawn because that pin to the
queen is so nasty and none of white's pieces
can really come to its defense yeah and lauren
says queen d7 he's thinking for the checkmate he's
like well i'll lead with my queen and there could
be some knight f4 check sacrifices with you know
queen h3 to follow actually can he get away with
that i was just saying h3 and bishop g4 yeah i was
sort of saying it in broad terms but now that i'm
looking at it that could work that would be nuts
and there he goes so queen h3 king h1 bishop g4
and then if rookie three you just take back on f4
is what i was thinking and you're hitting
everything hitting the knight hitting yeah
literally every piece i don't think this changes
anything you can still go queen h3 it's the same
line although now you can move your knight so
knight h4 i'm not sure if that's a good move
but at least you stop checkmate bishop g4 you
could put pawn f3 to block the bishop so there's
a little more flexibility in the approach you
can also take on a four with the bishop on uh
c1 i don't really like that because e takes f4 and
your knight and c3 hangs this is a wild position
this is spicy already i think lawrence is if this
works like if you can play knight f4 and it can't
be taken you're already on the right path that's
right and you just can't get complacent right you
had a good tactic but you need to keep it up and
for roberto he's down over half a minute on the
clock he's trying to figure out can i take this
knight into four do i just have to leave it there
should i play knight h4 that also looks wrong
because even a move like bishop f6 to just
try to take that knight looks pretty good for
black and he plays rook g1 when it's all said
and done but bishop g4 it looks menacing
but maybe that knight nc5 can be captured
come on what's going on here man well what's
going on is you just came up with a cantism
ricci won and it's all said and done that's that's
one right there we gotta we gotta remember that
one rook g1 it's all said and done uh bishop g4
i what's going on i literally have no idea but
i love it for black i'm here for it this this is
exactly what lawrence wants from every game if he
could if he could have it he would play this way
every single game and i love him got f4 coming
he's got a knight that's hanging on the board but
he plays bishop g4 and he says i don't care at all
so if you take the knight queen h5 you're going to
lose your knight in f3 can you just sacrifice your
queen not my queen but i move like knight h4 there
or something so take my queen i'll take back with
my bishop your queen on h5 is in trouble you're
not in the f4 is under attack i'm threatening you
on the queen side with my pawn i think that might
be the practical choice necessary but you have
28 seconds counting down now for roberto you just
need to move and i'm sacking my queen for sure now
yeah it's crazy at this point you have to come to
that conclusion that it's a good idea and that's
so hard to do it really is um taking this knight
and then giving up the queen i think you win this
night as well so you do get your three pieces but
if he doesn't find that i think he's just lost
he's got six seconds and the clock is ticking okay
he does take it so that he makes the good decision
but he doesn't have enough time left to keep
on playing wow all right he does it he's a very
good bullet player though if he doesn't lose his
game ahmad that's insane it's absolutely insane
but two minutes to four seconds this position is
harder to play for black from oh there's nothing
left to play because it's okay do you see roberto
he is so angry and i don't even think he looked
at his clock really and lawrence was like yes i
did it i'm he was so proud of himself there but
honestly from a chess perspective just that
final position was so immensely complicated
i think it was easier to play for white if
roberto was able to get his move off yeah
no this this is like uh the the type of chess that
we're seeing right here you've said it and i'll
just echo it again it's really high level like
both guys are playing really well the games like
there's blunders here and there but this is speed
chess you're gonna have pieces hanging from time
to time you're gonna have blenders but we haven't
seen egregious egregious mistakes yet um so i just
think we've been treated to a very high level
match and lawrence the underdog surely coming
into this is performing he's up two games right
now setting us up for a potential lead from him
going into the bullet and a very exciting finish
robert and we have seen swings before lawrence he
was jetting out to a two-game lead in the longest
time patrol roberto stormed right back to tie it
so right now we're going to break lawrence
trent is really thrilled about his performance
he's up two games but roberto molina will try to
bounce back remain seated we'll be back shortly
so
and we return lawrence trent with a six to four
lead over roberto molina amman lawrence has
been mighty impressive it's been shaky for both
players at times but ultimately this has been a
well fought match and i think lawrence has earned
his lead thus far absolutely and uh not only has
this been a great match entertaining from both
sides there's been their fair share of blunders
there's been a very high level match and when
you have these high level matches someone has
the lead it's fully deserved like when people are
flagging in this time control they have a tough
position like in this match we haven't seen
people uh just running out of time with a
completely winning position which we've seen in so
many speedchest matches what we're seeing here are
players putting their opponents in tough positions
and then the clock running out so all the the
points that the players have feel totally deserved
and we have six four right now for lawrence trent
we're at the halfway point of the three minute
portion and uh is your feeling that lawrence
has to keep up a lead going into the bullet or
i mean if it's a tied match it could be anyone's
uh game in the bullet portion yeah at first i
would have said that he would definitely need a
lead but the way he's been playing and the time
travel that roberto's been getting into i think
lawrence is better prepared and he understands
the foundations of these positions very well
right and back to this um same line that they they
played last time and now allowing a5 is roberto so
last time he played a5 and this was one of the
games robert that you were mentioning uh roberto
might be the first to admit that wasn't his best
game uh in the format yeah it really wasn't and
it went from locked up to tactical all of a sudden
and i don't think he made the switch that well
and look at lawrence he says i'm going to take
on d3 with my pawn my pawn structure is not very
good but what are you going to do for black how
are you going to break in this position oh guess
what you're going to play c5 well that undoubles
my pawns in the process so lawrence i don't like
the look of his pawn structure but it is his type
of position even if it's not mine yeah and when i
see f4 i was going to say the first move i would
play is h5 and the reason that f5 is being played
is i mean if you just look at the position
with the move like g5 in there black goes g6
locks everything up all light square pawns dark
square bishops on the board would be really good
for black so uh he's played f5 and i think this is
the perfect reaction whether it's the best move or
not you can't allow the thing the position to get
locked up and he takes on f5 so lawrence i think
he's gonna take back there he goes and this looks
really promising for white all of a sudden but
roberto is just saying hey i don't care i'm gonna
castle queen side get out of trouble this this
looks sketchy to me very sketchy bishop f4 um okay
so pawn being hit on f5 and you can't protect it
yeah i know you like queen f3 it's kind of crazy
wait did he like wait for knight f3 so that he
could play 97 was he being a trickster there it
looked like it i mean 97 was played as a follow-up
to pawn takes pawn which doesn't seem really
to do anything and then knight f3 just kind of
nonchalant and then 97 it's like wait a minute now
he has to play well f6 and e6 neither move looks
really good no they don't and the pawn structure
wasn't good for white to start with the doubled
pawns in the d-file here and now f5 is falling
so is there a way to quickly say castle get your
rook to the open f file and attack or is it just a
pawn that you're being you're handing over to your
opponent it looks like a pawn you're handing over
i i don't really see a way out i mean queen g3 is
available um taking a knight f6 this definitely
doesn't smell right but you know lawrence is
gonna be one to complicate things instead of just
handing over a pawn even if handing over the pawn
is maybe the smarter or more objective choice
and it is complicated indeed because queen g3
check can be played roberto refrains from doing
so he can do so again now but he chooses not to so
he just says i'm going to get your pawn e6 i
can play queen d6 go after that pawn i can go
knight f5 bring my knight to g3 i can castle
queen side and you don't really have an attack
so somehow this has turned in roberto's favor very
quickly yeah the the thing about the position here
for um lawrence is that his issues are on the
light squares like knight f5 and hg4 are both
going to happen there might be a long castle but
to be honest even short castling makes probably
even more sense for a rubric if he can get short
castles here safely knight f5 bishop e7 or d6
there's still queen g3 looming now there's knight
g3 this is just looking better and better um for
black because the pawns on the queen side look how
they're fixed nothing can move here and this pawn
chain for black is really really solid and rook
g1 played which means that lawrence is going to
castle queenside because he can't castle kingston
anymore so i i think bishop d6 just developed
castle kingside as you said and roberto's king is
safe there because of the light square diamonds is
lawrence going to be able to sacrifice like a rook
on g4 and exchange there and try to get an attack
i don't see it happening though no this looks like
it could be one of the cleaner games we've seen
from this match where it almost looks one-sided
from the start there was that one game lawrence
had which looked like pure tilt near the end of
the five minute where it was like just honestly
a very short game and roberto cleaned that one
up but this looks like uh you know a throwback
to that because kingside castle rook a to e8 if
white ever castles queenside there's queen takes
a5 as well this is just looking crushing and this
is the downside of lawrence's style we've seen
the benefits he's played some marvelous attacking
chess but he is he he tunnels he's like i want to
attack and checkmate my opponent and this happens
with people of various styles sometimes if you're
too positional you may miss tactics and then get
squeezed down because you give up all the space so
it is a stylistic decision and i think that it is
backfiring in this game overall it's worked out
right now as you said rook a to e8 rook f6 just
win this pawn on e6 and once the position opens up
it's white's king that's just a big danger
and it's kind of a funny move if king c2 i was
really looking at knight h2 as like a a funny
way that i think it seems to me like it just
wins actually yes you're trying to distract
that knight from the d4 pawn and well that's
why knight g5 doesn't work because knight g5
would defend the e6 pawn but you're dropping
d4 then the knight hits the queen goes knight p3
check everything is falling apart and the reason
that lawrence played king c1 is he didn't want to
put his king and queen on a square knight d4 what
happened so that he could play knight g5 let's
be clear knight d4 threatens knight b3 it wins
a pawn in the center i mean knight f2 hits the d3
pawn and the queen it does allow queen takes h5 so
i certainly wouldn't uh wouldn't consider it but
just knight takes e6 he's just going so solid so
so comfortable here roberto's gonna take this
game it's like minus six in this position
robert two extra pawns but the it's overwhelming
and rook a4 is a good move when you think that
that rook was doing nothing maybe there will be a
sacrifice on g4 but that seems like way too little
way too late and black can play rook f2 here
bishop f4 to follow just taking over the board
okay well is he gonna sacrifice here i feel like
it's almost necessary um i don't think it's good
he's gonna take with the queen bishop f4 looks
like a strong response looking for a queen trade
again there's little that white can do your your
attack whatever you think your attack's going to
be it doesn't happen nearly quickly but i didn't
like queen of seven invited the pawn to g6 and
queen h5 is next for the time as well let's
not forget about the clock guys 10 seconds
ticking down here and lawrence is getting some
of his attack going and look at that move queen
to g7 hitting the rook hitting the bishop where
would he even go here seven seconds queen if it
might be the only move hard move the fight look
he just dropped the bishop also queen e6 check
and then try to get the rook to the h file white
is better that's better this is ridiculous wow and
we were just praising roberto for playing like a
pristine game and now he's much worse he's trying
to somehow hold take on g6 okay the worst of your
problems will be behind you once you take on g6
but now that a5 pawn which is weak the whole game
is going to queen that a pawn is a big problem
and queen h6 is crushing that looks like a great
move as well right knight f6 check where's that
king going oh my gosh where's the discover check
what where do we go what wait that's 88 that seems
just wrong okay but he has knight d6 barely holy
things on here no knight c doesn't work because
their king would be in check it's like a nice fork
tactic that back everyone has three seconds in
this game this is just wild the g pawn runs okay
rookie to check the king goes d3 you drop b2 so g4
and g3 keep it going the bishop covers g1 that's
important to remember but the bishop does not
match a8 i know it may oh okay this is getting
increasingly relevant you know oh my goodness
a7 but white's doing well here
yeah should just be totally winning
knight takes b5 and then bishop a3 oh my
god one time oh lords freaked out oh my god
it's totally winning oh my gosh lawrence just
freaked out and uh my portuguese is not good
enough to to know what roberto molina just
muttered under his breath there but i'm sure
it was a fine compliment towards his opponent yes
and uh you lucky fill in the blank yeah himself
wow what a reaction what an end to that game that
it just feels like people are are playing so well
these matches are are flipping around back
and forth what we've actually seen being the
weakness of these players it seems like converting
advantages that that's the story of this match so
far and they just lose sight of their clocks
we saw roberto in the game before the break
he sacrificed his queen but they just lost some
time and he spent so much time calculating it
that he had no time remaining so both players
have been finding great ideas to survive the
defensive resourcefulness has been amazing with
little time in the clock but yet the conversion
part that's been a failure yeah for both of them
yep and we talked about trading pieces here's
one of those games everything is gone and that's
almost like i feel like it's almost both players
just relaxing a little bit that's an incredibly
adrenaline-filled match and now we just get the
guys okay let's just trade let's just have
one of these games it should be a dead draw
but uh roberto controls the only open file on the
board and if i had to pick a color i'd probably
take white oh for sure and it's one of these
situations where you're like oh my gosh i know
i need to draw this game i should draw but then i
make one inaccuracy and i'm on the defensive for
the rest of the game for example like if queen d6
happens and black is forced to trade there that is
zero fun for you and the king gets in and white's
piece is just more active so i think that what
lords has done is the right thing he was trying to
create some inroads in the queen side and now his
queen remains active and his rook is also free to
join the party in a second yeah this is nice this
is nice um i would take that a3 is something you
give consideration to but not really when b4 is
on the table right and i would consider queen d4
for black like let you took over the d file first
i'm going to take it back now and if you take me
i have a pass pawn in the center so instead queen
b4 makes perfect sense as well i feel like
both sides are just looking at this position
knowing that it should be equal with best play and
coming up with a real plan is not easy so h4 why
not doesn't probably see h5 for the same reason
why not yeah i don't have an answer well okay now
white can consider h5 and the point is to get h6
and there it goes yeah this feels like the first
substantial mistake i would say it's not that it's
losing for black it's nothing that drastic but if
you if you play h6 you're just tying black down
to the defensive yep so brook d4 is fantastic by
lawrence i would have played queen e3 before the
rook got to the d-file you want to support this
h-pawn that's going to tie the king down and just
you know be a nuisance basically later in the game
if this gets taken he wants to say look i got rook
b8 h6 and there's just going to be some sort of
meeting net ideas in the position at all times
that's right and look at that pawn h6 how does
black accurately fend off most of the pressure
it's not that black is going to check for rook a1
threatens checkmate i don't think you can actually
trade rooks the resulting position looks very bad
for uh for black i think he might be going to
but i'm not sure that it's so good he might
be underestimating well with rook a8 coming you
might have to play rook d1 and maybe there's just
trade on d1 and then black queen goes to c2
just to i that e4 pawn but the issue remains
that at some moment bl white could just give
up some pawns and go checkmate so queen d8
give up the b4 pawn queen vertex before there's
even queen d2 or queen g5 is an idea so two iii
takes ticket exactly game over and that's just a
terrible blunder the game's over and just resigned
and well not on this game over lawrence on camera
was over he just went away he is really angry at
this point and roberto two straight games he has
won on a blunder but i will give full credit to
roberto his strategy in that game was perfect he
said there will be zero tactics available to you
we're playing a positional game i have the open
file first i pushed my h-pawn and lawrence just
didn't react in the best manner yeah and to me
it's so strange in those symmetrical positions
when someone plays h4 like you just play h5
don't even think about it i mentioned like
yeah just play h5 because why not but that's the
structure you want letting white play h5 i know
you were mentioning oh this is kind of a mistake
but it's hard to call that a big blunder when
we're commentating because i mean okay allowing
h5 isn't a big deal but that was the difference
that was the game it gave white a plan and before
that point they were just kind of hey let's move
here i'll move there so what but you're right
that he gave what a clear plan and then lawrence
of queen d8 to stop the queen infiltrating on
the dark squares and then he blended his rook
the next move so that was a tough go of things for
lawrence right now he's the better pawn structure
black's pawns are split on the queen side a5
and c6 pod's best friend being another pawn you
would like to protect in that manner however black
gets quick activity thanks to this d5 square the
semi-open b-file with a rook b8 could be a nice
thing the b4 square bishop coming to c5 i see
the pieces coming alive right now for black and
i'm actually starting to appreciate roberto's
position more and more yeah although i like what
lawrence has done i think preemptively g3 to cut
knight f4 knight on e3 bishop d2 covering all
the squares the knight might want to move to
so we'll see things like king e2 uh rook h to c1
or rook a to c1 and i think lawrence is probably
decently happy here he has something to play for
and now he's hinting maybe he wants to play knight
to c4 and wow king d7 now that is a move that
i like but at first i wouldn't even considered
it but look at this the d5 knight covers the b6
square no check for you there he can now bring
his rook from h8 there it goes very quickly to
b8 and the king is perfect on d7 it will never
be attacked the pawn c6 is defended because
of that king so i like what roberto has done
but now that we're here come on what's the
plan for either side yeah i mean white has
i think a few moves uh left in the tank
like maybe rook to c1 or d1 from the h file
there's f4 that you know white always has in
his mind to fully connect that pawn chain um
a3 is something i would consider as white but
i think for now i'd probably leave it as it is
just on a2 so if a3 happens by black i have the
option to go b3 or take that a3 just gives up the
b3 square and i'm just not sure about that one
i don't like it so i think i'd bring the rook
in maybe try to connect the pawns and bishop to
b4 is looking to say hey i want to trade bishops
and then play knight b4 and that looks like a good
plan absolutely so it was interesting that this
game is might come down to the move a3 for either
side whether it's good or not remains to be seen
but there is that idea for both going forward
so h6 by roberto just playing slowly that pawn
was under attack it should not have been captured
don't go full fisher your bishop would have been
caught over there but you just don't even want
to worry about that and so he plays h6 now what
is white's move here how do you improve your
position rook d to c2 trying to double in the
file the knight to before that doesn't look good
so he plays h4 and maybe he'll play f4 king f3
g4 and try to use the king side push but does that
really get you anywhere um i don't know if black
has any threats upcoming i mean the idea of like
rook b7 taking and taking on b2 definitely comes
to mind but you can take with the rook potentially
and think about this pawn there's all sorts of
long-term considerations white on the other hand
h5 followed by f4 doesn't seem like a bad way
to fix those pawns on the king's side that's
very true and it said lawrence goes knight d6
he trades off the bishops the f7 pawn isn't an
attack and or bert says it may be under attack
but your knight isn't well defended i'm just
gonna play f6 and if f4 will black trade on e5
and bring the rook from b8 to f8 i guess that
would have been a thought and king of the hill
what a move game over right king of the hill it's
it's uh it's a winner lawrence is uh gonna get
out of his chair and start screaming that the the
game isn't over yet this is some issue and you can
play rook a7 to b7 here because the knight on d6
can't capture the rook without dropping the rook
on c4 so if you want to keep this tension
alive rook a to b7 feels like a good move
look at him he is reading your mind right now rook
b7 and uh b2 is hanging here as well um because i
think again if you take that there's rook takes on
d2 so actually does come packed with a threat and
if you take right you give up some ground there
and the e5 pawn could drop and the d6 knight loses
its stronghold so right now it's a tough moment
for lawrence and he is down by nearly 20 seconds
at this point so he needs to start moving more
quickly it's just a tough position to figure out
yeah and what what a match we've had it's been
you know different leaders at different points um
i'm trying to think back to the beginning of this
this match but uh it feels like lawrence has been
the only one with a lead so far is that is that
right i don't think roberto has been ahead so far
he's never been tied but i don't think he's been
ahead that's correct he lost game one he won game
two and then lauren started with a winning streak
he came back but he has never taken the lead
he's on verge right now this is dangerous
territory for lawrence we've seen him react
to blunders to losing on time all this stuff
if he goes down the match that could spell
full disaster and he can go on tilt but look at
this it's locked up over here i'm not sure who
i prefer this position for because the knight on
d5 is really strong but so it's that knight on d6
yeah and i don't know about like my instinct would
be king d4 maybe there was something wrong with
king d4 but i would have played that instead of
king f3 yeah maybe there was word a timely g5 it
doesn't well you can consider g5 yeah even here
it's has a lot of risk though yeah g5 the idea
being um if you play f takes and h5 that might
be the issue and i guess there's this and well
if you go and distract yourself on the king side
can i wait and then go rook h4 like if you go rook
takes g5 can you say rook h4 and win your a4 pawn
right wow the cross board gameplay there rook h4
going all the way back over to collect that a pawn
and then going rook a7 check and black of course
wants to say look i'm bringing the king up the
board there's no way i'm going backwards the king
d8 i think you have to do something on the queen
side play for your past c pawn so a3 giving up a
pawn or in this case yeah before to start winning
some of these queen side pawns you need to try to
promote that c part e5 is falling so knight f7 an
ugly move but perhaps force and look at however
what do you do though yeah this is looking very
difficult knight takes e5 check maybe we'll get
a liquidation and you just play rook a8 but king
of six don't take the pawn right away your rook
is defending yeah oh i would have gotten king
f6 okay still i probably prefer black though
um e5 e4 just by a small amount though smaller
yes black is more active the rook on g4 cuts
the king off he can play e4 check the king
goes back to f2 and there goes black's king
but i think lawrence has enough to hold this
position the king definitely should and he is
going to be livid if he does not hold this because
that that's just the wrong wrong energy to have
you need to hold this draw and i think he oh that
wasn't maybe the best rookies b3 oh my goodness
and look at lawrence look at lawrence he cannot
believe it he's beside himself it's just not
acceptable he he had to draw technique it was
just check check check check back and forth
and grook d3 don't i don't even get away with that
so he goes king c4 that's smart and now king is
just gonna collect the pawn yes oh that's a good
move though that's a really good movie that's a
really really good move but unfortunately roberto
knew how to meet it just pushed that one yeah yeah
wow this is going to be a loss for for
lawrence i think at this point there's
just too much time uh and he's gonna get rook
e1 check oh okay would have maybe checked but
same ideas yeah you cut the king off and now you
build the bridge so this actually is instructive
for most of our viewers and how to win this end
game and look at the rookton d5 don't trade the
rooks just yet the king would be allowed back in
front of the pawn you just wait you bring your
king in and then you promote so win for roberto
and we've been saying that a lot because i think
it's been well at least three in a row um if not
more but yeah i think three wins in a row for uh
roberto molino from brazil this is this is crazy
right now lawrence is just falling apart and he's
doing it at the worst time this might be the last
three minute game imagine that this trends even
more and more in roberto's direction it's gonna
be eight to six and with with just a collapse in
the three-minute portion that's not what you need
going into bullet no it is not and i will say that
this type of position it could get quite tactical
so i like how the opening has gone for lawrence
but i wonder amon was lawrence like weirdly
playing for a win there why would he bring his
rook to c4 in the play pushes apon what was that
about i don't i don't know i think i think he was
not playing for a win um i think it was just you
know he saw the opportunity rook c4 good square
for the rook when the king was there and just sort
of overestimated the the idea that you don't have
to do anything when you're looking for a draw or
you're looking to hold a position sometimes doing
nothing is the best thing to do and he tried to
do something and he didn't have anything to do
and he just saw the apon he's like well there's
something i can throw up the board so i think it
was just a product of trying to do something when
nothing was necessary to do at all i think that's
right that's what happened and for lawrence he
probably was getting nervous at that point and
he pushed his pawn thinking that he would lose
it regardless but that dropped the b3 pawn which
was an issue and now in this game well roberto i i
like how the opening went for lawrence but i don't
like this position for him because if we look
at the quality of pieces and what squares can be
hours from taking the light squares all over here
are going to be under white's control and he can
take here play pawn to b5 knight into d5 and what
is black going to do about any of this rook to a1
yeah at this point i think this is
exactly where roberto wants to be
comfortable playing a positional game uh
there's not a lot of dangerous tactics i mean
there's still pieces on the board but it's really
reminiscent of that earlier game that they played
i think it was the second game of the match where
lawrence had these exact two pieces on the board a
knight and a dark square bishop and we were it
was just a you know race can he activate them
make some threats or is this going to be
an end game and here c5 looks very powerful
you can never take with the d-pawn because the
rook will land on d7 winning your queen and he
makes a retreating move which is good because
they attacked the rook he just repeated once
that's a nice thing now bishop takes e5
as a threat if lawrence didn't see it
that's a grip a great point it's c5 so the thing
is i think he went back to e4 because he noticed
c5 after he did it he was like oh let's go back
see if he goes back to a2 now he plays c5 anyway
and i actually like this decision from lawrence
even though his position is bad that he can't just
get squeezed like this he needs to do something
with his pieces and sometimes you drop a pawn
but the rest of your pieces feel happier here c5
is hanging e5 is hanging but look at this move
rook a2 it's much more lawrence's style to play in
this manner he defends with an offense rather than
just sitting passively yep and i'm wondering what
the follow-up is if you move that queen too far
away from that e pawn bishop takes e3 bishop d4
happens and that's that's over right there and e4
the reason that that's kind of an annoying move
um for white actually is that the bishop controls
d2 so it's like it's kind of a hard pin to get
out of or it's just a little bit awkward here
uh for roberto right and if you go rook takes c5
there could be queen b6 if you're unaware of this
the bishop is hanging but rook d7 check will win
the queen that is a brilliant move by roberto
here is rook a6 or queen a6 needed here oh
both of those moves do not look fun though
bishop takes e5 maybe just grab the central pawn
how else do we do it i don't know um yeah rook d7
looks pretty strong just to trade queens he might
prefer that because the queen's good off the board
that is bishop looks solid that's a very roberto
decision to make but right now he takes on e5 he
he has the sense that this match is really turning
in his favor and if he can win this game the final
game of the three plus one time drill he'll exit
with a two-game lead and he came into it you know
earlier in the match with a two-game deficit
so yeah what a comeback it's been by roberto
yeah and and this three minute portion it says
three and a half to two and a half i'm pretty sure
that it started with like a draw and then it was
two wins from lawrence so he has actually won
four straight games i think it might even be or
something to that effect the point is he's made
an insane comeback in this three minute portion
and if you can cap it off with a win here then
you go into the break all that confidence you're
up two games then the bullet happens where he
probably thinks he should be the favorite lawrence
needs to tie this match right now because he has
been letting his emotions get the better of him
and i think he needs a win to get back on track
i would agree and well as king is on h6 so i
don't know about winning this game but roberto and
lawrence about even in the clock white's position
is better it's even material both sides have two
rooks queen bishop and four pawns but there's a
king on h6 out in the open the c5 pawn the c7 pawn
both are weak and queen b2 i think just wins in
the spot hitting the g7 square and the rook on a3
wow queen b2 is a sneaky sneaky bishop
g7 check um i guess there's rook a8 there
but it still looks like a really good move and
maybe it didn't win but i looked at it i was
like well the g7 score is where i want to go
and it looks like it should have been winning
this still so yeah this looks fantastic um
still hope for lawrence like i would maybe
go like bishop e7 almost bishop f6 i think if you
trade the the bishops it's very very scary because
the pieces just pile up on the on the c pawn
white needs to also play like something like h3
um just to get an escape score for that
king and what about this trade because
this could turn into a position where let's say
one more piece gets traded after the bishops
let's say the queens get traded and now europe
would probably be up upon regardless these one
of the c pawns will drop but is that
enough material to win that's difficult
holy that's a good one rook d8 because if you
get a queen end game the king is tucked on each
one and you have a pass pawn that is a lot more
mobile than that e pawn the black king can catch
uh white's epon a lot easier than white's king
can catch the c pawn with the help of the queen
and he could have traded rooks and taken the c5
pawn but the same situation would have existed
where black would have been down to palm but
the c pawn with the queen would have started
rolling up the board so here oh there's no way
white can win this game the king is stuck in
the corner and in fact lawrence might be able to
somehow take this over if queen takes c5 is played
rook do you want check so do not take that
pawn if i'm lawrence yeah give up that pawn
it's almost too obvious right you shouldn't
have attacked the queen lauren you should have
left it just randomly over there but c4 d2 c or
rook d2 or c4 keep pushing those pieces and go
after white's king the problem is black's king
is also very exposed so there will likely be
f4 and rook c5 oh f4 check was winning but queen
of fate's also good so what's what's the idea
oh he's just setting that up and queen quincy
five you in the rook queens if i wins the rule
he sees it lawrence is gonna is gonna exit
this three-minute portion in terrible shape
did you see that he looked scared like he
didn't even look surprised he looked like
he was frightened by what just happened and he
is distraught he is devastated look at the guy
he's not even on camera anymore not even he's not
even there it's the the headless horseman wow wow
borderline's speechless but that game seems like
if we just look at the conclusion there lawrence's
reaction you know the blunder all this stuff but
roberto kept up the pressure throughout the game
and he had a beautiful game towards the end there
he went astray lawrence was able to actually have
a better position more active position but the
whole game roberto put him under pressure and then
in the end he spotted tactics when lawrence tried
too hard to win yeah and that's set up with queen
f8 rook f1 just to play the pawn to f4 that was
beautiful and lawrence just just collapsed in that
three-minute portion i mean he looked frightened
as you said like literally frightened to see queen
c5 on the board that's like you know finding
something weird out from ancestry.com reports
he looked surprised and we are surprised as well
that the leader of this match is actually roberto
going into the bullet uh i mean if there's
anything uh a tilted player wants to play
robert it's bullet chess so i'm excited for the
the next portion so my everybody will come back
shortly with the bullet portion of this match it
is a two game lead for roberto molina but lawrence
trent has that aggressive style to mount a
comeback stay tuned we'll be back shortly
we have yet to determine who will move on to
the semi-finals but we know that it will be a
tough battle between the winner of this match and
the winner of lars oscar hogg and teddy coleman
aman what do you think what do you think
about this bracket what do we have in
store for the remaining matches well it's a
really uh interesting question because the
the first round has finally been concluded this
is the first look at these next set of matches and
lars oscar and teddy coleman the thing about teddy
is you know you just can't bet against teddy such
a solid player he is always always in the match no
matter if his opponent is much higher rated than
him or not lars of course going in is obviously
the favorite but um i don't think that that match
is said and done because lars did look a little
bit shaky however showed up in the bullet portion
whereas roberto and lawrence were waiting to be
decided but you know the winner of this match is
going to face the winner of lars and teddy so
i think if we get a match-up like for example
teddy and uh roberto it could just be the most
solid match we've ever seen and if we get lars
against lawrence it could just be tactics every
single game so i'm excited for that no matter what
for sure and i know that many people out there are
especially excited for the matchup between levy
rosman that is gotham chess and eric rosen eric
did win his game his match excuse me yesterday
against sagrasha so that will be a fun one indeed
between two of the best content creators out there
and two friendly personalities that people i'm
sure will have a very big rooting interest in
yeah they'll definitely see some uh some firm
opinions uh about who they want to win that
match but for now we're getting into the bullet
section robert of this match and i i mentioned
and i i meant it that you know what does a tilted
player want to do he wants to play bullet chest do
you think this is going to bode well for him here
robert look at this 92 e5 i think he has chances
but look at roberto's bullet rating that is not
a mistake that is 28.59 so lawrence has his work
cut out for him but i like the opening choice even
if i don't understand a single move play this far
yeah no i mean uh basically what we see here
is lawrence has uh you know a heavyweight
uh to take care of a 28 59 in bullet roberto is
no joke and uh this everything we've seen in the
match so far might just get accentuated in bullets
so i think we're either getting a very close match
or we could just see a blowout from roberto
yeah i think it's a fair call and right now the
position somehow looks relatively normal after the
very strange start white can put the pawn on d4
if he so chooses put a knight on e5 we have an iqp
position but i like that lawrence is refraining
from pushing the d-pawn the bishop on b2 is much
stronger without that pawn in its path yeah knight
c4 just hitting that bishop but we do see the
night getting into e5 the bishop will return
at some point to to b2 and there it goes rookie
one and those bishops eyeballing the king side
i think this is a position that lawrence is
probably happy to get you know might not be
the most sound but hey everything's pointing
in one direction you know where the action is
well if there's is there ever a time for harry
styles reference it was after you just said one
direction but right now i'm looking at the king
side as well g6 is a very scary move to have to
play for black because that fish won't be two now
it has the full length of diagonal and i'm looking
at tactics right if you remove the knight from
e5 knight g4 right just when they get on the spot
that has to be e5 i was gonna say it's the only
try knight takes f6 queen takes f6 and run the
king that's all we got can i just take on e5
instead like i just go knight back and take on e5
he doesn't he goes to the h7 pawn okay probably
not the most uh forcing decision but um d4 if
he controls that e7 square keep in mind guys queen
h8 is check made in one that's true so actually is
lawrence winning another pawn it looks
like it to me and if he gets a second pawn
then he's well on his way here and yes roberto's
down 15 seconds yep and if that bishop ever leaves
that diagonal keep in mind bishop a3 is also going
to lead to well maybe maybe more but rook takes e5
queen takes e5 is a background check oh my god oh
that's a commentator's current oh and he missed it
i feel so much better i was about to
feel horrible that i just jinxed him and
how did both players miss that i thought at least
someone was was setting that up wow and the game
continues and lawrence is up on the clock he's
up two pawns he can push his pawn to d5 so king
g7 is not a possibility here there's no second
rank infiltration there's no rook c2 it's super
important yes and just take on h6 you just win a
pawn and we're going to check as a threat now d5
bishop f6 check everything is a problem for that
black king oh nice now d5 beautiful and just go
work age seven perhaps yeah this is a good move
as well and what's the count how many pawns is
white up bishop d4 three pawns yeah oh yeah this
is great he's simplifying as well f7 is hanging
i think lawrence has got this game three seconds
ticking down he's definitely got it and just d
takes c how many pass pawns does a player
need and you can't even protect f7 rookie
seven check is coming and he wins on time wow
and we this is how the entire match started
robert it was like oh wow roberto's coming
in with 27 50 blitz lawrence is the underdog
boom he absolutely crushed him game one same
thing in the bullet talking about 28 50 bullet
lawrence comes in and says hey it's not
about raiding it's all about the board baby
and and he comes in with a emphatic start to this
bullet portion yeah and right now it's only a one
point deficit and this is the type of position
that lawrence likes trying to get active here
but i like roberto's decision to go knight f3 to
d2 trade off that menacing knight in the center
now look at this it went from potentially tactical
to a positional battle because it's not opening
up yet and i'm not a fan of knight on g6 f4
looks like a great move because it's going to
be followed up by exactly that e4 knight takes
e4 and already roberto is dictating the pace
he is and the queen on e8 is not happy to see
the e-file open up the rook on e1 will win that
battle and knight g5 comes to mind here yep just
trying to open up more of the board the d6 pawn
is hanging so knight takes d6 can be played fs5
also looked quite tempting there but hey knight d6
you know free pawn open bishops
this is just commanding for roberto
all right so let's see how can black get back
into this thing that's what you have to come up
with if you're lawrence you're down on the clock
in addition to being down a pawn so what can you
do if the light square bishops get traded maybe
then you feel like you have some hope i like the
move h5 it's just me too creating vague threats
of a kingside attack and now he goes on the
other side of the board that's just honestly it's
disorienting rook d3 hit the g3 pawn just uh get
get involved in the position somehow rook e3 is
sort of covering that third rank because of that
i'd like to remove her to d3 that was probably
better and if this knight could just go to f5
black suddenly has a ton of compensation but now
the knight came before get there can i take on f4
just go bishop e5 and win my knight or something
or queen g5 yeah or even if i don't win the night
basically if i get you to play g5 i feel like
someone's getting mated and it's not me yeah and
now queen g5 is a good move because if you take
on f4 with the knight bishop e5 happens cutting
off your discover check winning the knight on f4
yep and i was gonna say i like b6 just to force
lawrence to say look are you committing to that
diagonal with queen b8 or not and i actually don't
feel like this is so overwhelming for white i
mean it should lead to an attack oh that's brookie
rookie what okay there's rookie two so you somehow
protect the rook there and i'm even looking at
moves like rook to d5 there just doesn't work
as the bishop will take around the pawn but
wow rookie has to be played okay it was
rook d but now he's getting out of this
yeah and he's got no time i would be moving the
black king uh by the way to like h7 or something
just like out of the way that seems like a
reasonable play and it said rook to b3 so he keeps
moving i like this move f6 that looks like that's
strong well if you move the rook though rook be
one check king f2 queen g3 mate so just don't lock
your king up to f2 but actually the queen coming
together rick g5 that's one should lead to me
okay he had to go rookie one check first i think
so both players seconds yeah
making mistakes in time troll yeah
this is playable oh it's very playable he doesn't
have time guys his position's okay watch out for
bishop takes c6 as a sacrifice if the rooks
get traded brooke takes g2 g2 oh my goodness
and now that's never k7 is happening with
bishop c6 yes and okay eight first good touch
seven rookie one check for k2 something
like that like just pin that bishop
yeah oh the king's coming to g3 oh
my gosh is gonna be a checkmate here
king king james three bishop bishop c4 yeah
bishop c4 key one the king's running away though
oh my goodness what the hell is going on here
i don't know i don't know f7 this looks like
it should be enough for white you're up a
piece now the b7 pawn well zombie seven yeah
wow what a great game lawrence is is saying
look i am here to play because he was absolutely
in that match after looking out of it for the
entire opening that was that was beautiful uh
play by lawrence to come back in that game
roberto just made the better decisions
you know towards the end of that match but uh
what a game robert and we have this opening
that we saw in game one and then we saw again
later in the match and lawrence has fixed it he
did not allow black to play e5 and said he put
e5 himself white is down to pawn but look at
these pieces your minor pieces are dominating
you can castle play knight g5 pawn h3 to trap
that knight oh knight h4 what a move taking
with the f5 squad trying to sacrifice some g6
take that uh for sure yep and well besides it's
funny i was looking at the king side and it goes
right these are like oh okay that's a freak
hanging as well yeah and now white must be
thrilled because you've regained the material and
the king stuck in the center bishop g5 as you said
excellent move where does that king go nowhere
bishop f8 sad movie play yeah sad but maybe
necessary and how do i end this game there's no
queen d3 trying to just take this pawn at five
if e6 there might be like a knight move to b5
or something like three four knight e4 or the
queen's protected actually be careful but knight
b5 you can't take the knight because queen takes
b5 is made so knight b5 going knight c7 check
could actually just pick up a bunch of material
oh my goodness what a move love it though
queen takes f5 and just how do you defend
you can't f7 is falling and very
importantly the bishop on g5 covers
the c1 square so if there's ever any kind
of queen c1 check you just steal the queen
this is a nasty game lawrence is gonna
strike back right away it looks like
yeah he's in fine form and i see teddy coleman
in the chat and he says does rook takes f5 work
so he was seeing the tactic that we weren't quite
focused on but look at this play by lawrence trent
rook back to f1 is probably sufficient here whoa
queen g6 he's just going to take everything but
where is the mate this is how winning positions
can go wrong wait he needed to take on e6 i think
there queen takes e6 to start he probably did
but knight no knight c5 check as bad as queen 65
queen 65 what a blunder he's the whole game he's
gone now and lawrence is in pain he just grimaced
there and wait what wait what just wait sorry
what yeah how did that just happen wasn't the d4
the d4 point was hanging with check and
me right sorry what just happened there c4
wait now white's winning wait wait that's an
outside passport i'm very confused g4 and then
just bring your king up and then play bishop
e3 to trade bishops at some point yeah king e4
bishop e3 although actually if you trade bishops
there could be a place where you can't get your
king in you need to be a bit careful about that so
just king can you bring his king to the queen side
i'm confused yeah this is the right
plan i think this is the good plan
black's gonna have to you know get his bishop to
attack the e pawn or something right but c5 falls
and that's the second pawn and now it's winning
at that moment what in the world did we just see
bishop e3 and i would play a4 nice move
yeah this is not easy even literally what was
that how do you play queen c5 but not notice the
so strange wow i wonder if he was just happy
to regain some material so he's like okay
like i'm not dead lost anymore and then he
just didn't find the next follow-up which
actually led to a forcing checkmate oh my goodness
so run the pawn to a6 i guess you may as well
don't know about g7 but okay it's all all winning
well the a pawn is the wrong pawn so if somehow
the king can win the g7 pawn you can run back the
other way but it's no it's not nearly anything
he's got it you didn't have to bring that bishop
back but i think he sees oh yeah that's sick
that's sick and nice touch there and if you're
roberto do you just spend the next 10 seconds you
waste the match clock he says no i don't think
he feels comfortable right now i was going to
say the same thing i i think as roberto as the
higher rated player you want as many both games
right now in the match as close as you can get
there's 13 minutes left but lawrence is leading
the bullet he entered down two games now he's only
down one and it has been such a nerve-wracking
state of games where both players have winning
chances may blunder then they're getting down
to the limit of their time but i think lawrence
has played better honestly in the bullet thus far
yep i agree i agree just overall even the games
that go really bad for him he had that one game
i just think that it's impressive he's able to
stay in and still generate winning chances at
some point generally if you play a bullet
game and you have no winning chances ever
start to finish your opponent has played just a
master class because it's bullet chess after all
things are going pretty fast completely agreed
and if we see this opening and how this is gone
at first doesn't say hey i like what lauren's
doing trying to play for f5 but then he made the
move bishop f6 was that a mouse slip uh i don't
know i feel like he he wants to put that bishop on
g7 but that's only after seeing bishop f6 when the
bishop's on e7 i wouldn't have ever suggested that
yeah so oh look at that move great exchange
sacrifice this is classy everybody if you take
the rook on c6 the pawn takes back the knight
was actually trapped and even if the knight
were not trapped is still a worthy sacrifice
and now the rook on c6 that's so powerful
yeah and that's just bullet chest for you
you want to look for those nasty moves where
you know your opponent just can't see the good way
to play um it's all about having a plan a bullet
and lawrence doesn't have a plan he wanted to go
for f5 he didn't do so and now f5 is off the table
because your king gets through he has to
trade right or b5 maybe okay b5 is clever
and now the queen drops back and now you're
more willing to trade because the pawn on c6
followed by pawn and b5 that would be a protected
pass pawn now if you take back with the pawn on
c6 that could become a target later in the game
lawrence is playing a bit better that b5 move was
key and i think he's starting to maybe become
optimistic about his position he does in fact
take now d takes c6 the d6 pawn is weak and the
knight is free to go to a5 but how does black
really fend the position because knight a5
doesn't really make a threat and hey you know
what lawrence just have to knight f4 queen h3
stuff here it comes and i thought queen b7 was
going to be roberto's move just to trade queens
before playing c7 instead he pushed the pawn
which objectively should be good as long as he
doesn't get checkmated and so queen takes a like
yes that's a great point queen takes eight just
wins right now although yeah yeah that's the
chances you need that's why he played f3 and
that's a great move the rook on c2 is also a
nice defender so now queen takes a8 he wants queen
a7 check by the way that's why he did this but um
maybe knight c5 after that i don't know lawrence
is very tricky with that move a5 you think he does
nothing six seconds he needs to move quickly queen
a seventh check yeah can you have one queen e3 you
get scared the next queen e3 oh no oh that's big
queen e3 the knights hanging on age three but
that's a movie
yeah resign lawrence you have to resign get a new
game resign resign yep new game that's okay even
in these games he has his chances and it seems
like with the white pieces lawrence has been way
more confident he has him but now he changed his
opening back to some main lines and i don't like
this because it's very solid for black it may be
slightly better for white and know the two bishops
all that good stuff but look at this the queens
are oh this is good for black if you win this game
it's going to take you several minutes and 100
moves several minutes 100 moves great technique
i mean just everything and lauren's off to a good
start though he has the pawn to c4 d4 right now he
plays g4 trying to use the bishops but this is
the problem when you claim i have a two bishops
revenge is your light square bishop actually that
strong the answer is no because all of black's
pawns are on light squares that can be good if
you can attack the pawns but how are you going to
attack f7 you can so look at this position i think
it's very pleasant for black even better bishop f6
this is so so brutal when
you got that two-game deficit
and you're just looking at the position
you're just not happy with what you see
now bishop f6 after rook h1 and you're even just
worse you're winning all the pawns terrible oh no
and and the worst part about this is you can't
make a draw anytime soon even if you are able
to save the half point which may not be likely at
this point in time but it's going to take forever
so you have to sit there and watch your opponent
try to play for a win and knowing that you have
a very good chance of losing this after
wasting like three more minutes minimum
that's right and lawrence he can go rook h.a
rook just start over the queen side attack
those pawns and maybe now it's not that bad
for him it looks hard to press for black but
actually how does black try to win here um
maybe like rook h7 rick h3 with e4 that's i
think the way to go right you need to push your
past pawns and your extra pawn is in the center
so a5 is a consideration for lawrence just to try
to break down black's queen-side pawn structure
but he can also put his work on d5 right anyway
he's gonna get a bunch of checks lawrence isn't
defending this really well he is he is in full
credit there's 45 seconds a piece the only problem
is there's so much shuffling going on right now
the time is not going down here comes f4 and you
have to go back right king e4 rook d4 checkmate
that would not have been fun and the problem with
playing f4 is now e4 is harder to accomplish so
you're not creating the past pawn but the good
news is you kick that king back as you mentioned
and rook f8 check just keep checking this king
brook back to e8 the worst part iman is the 50
move rule counter restarted when f4 was played
and now it's going again but lawrence
is doing this perfectly this is a draw
yeah it is but i think roberto
is also doing this perfectly
from the perspective of the match right and oh now
you're dropping the c5 pawn can't take c5 and then
you just keep the king cut off but you're gonna
play so many more moves here so many more moves
rook c4 to d4 get your king back involved or this
yeah and white just needs to keep the king cut off
look at that like it you might not notice it guys
but that match clock it was like at 10 minutes
when this game started or more this is really
really bad news for lawrence and you need to be
able to start the last game so right now down
two points let's say lawrence wins a game with
10 seconds left that's still good he still gets
that final game so you're very much keeping on
the match clock in here lawrence is holding
the draw he's playing this very well but it's
getting lower and lower on the clock where he
can't afford any more draws after robredo can play
until the match clock's at like two minutes
um literally this could last four more minutes
oh and here comes the king
watch out okay rook a3 was
okay or this is yeah then you can go rook a3
after king e3 lawrence he's doing a great job
yeah this is just a bunch of random moves
essentially hoping that lawrence goes wrong
and for lawrence he's just like this is painful
but i am digging deep and i'm holding this game
rook d5 now rook d5 there we go that's that's
actually the first mistake from roberto molina
and now now this is a lot easier in fact
he's going to collect most of these puns
oh man the black can keep playing this after this
that's crazy maybe it was smart to lose that pawn
oh now he's going to lose the f pawn and lawrence
is going to play it oh my god it's still going to
be a draw oh god that was a mouse lit but
no that's a great move what a move rook g4
by the way why didn't lawrence take that is he
trolling take that make your draw yeah maybe
he's trying to win now but that's ridiculous yeah
he should have taken he's shooting himself in the
foot dude take the rock what are you doing okay he
just wasted his own time there wow rook g4 though
that was excellent yeah that's just like one of
those moves that isn't necessary to play but it's
cool when you see it that is 100 the best move in
the position and to see it in time trouble in a
bullet scramble when this match is on the line
that was well done by roberto because all of a
sudden lawrence won one pawn and was about to win
the second and then he really could have tried to
play for a win but roberto he is too smooth there
he finds a way out queen f3 the d4 pawn can i
capture that at some point soon talk about smooth
i mean look at these games that he's get what
lawrence where's the conviction we need we need uh
like f5 in that position we need e5 i don't know
we need c5 we need moves because look the clock is
ticking down it's four minutes and this is just a
boring everything defends everything position
yeah f5 was a really good move there probably
would have won black a pawn but maybe lawrence
just saw what roberto did he said hey you know
piling up on the d file and trying to uh outplay
my opponent end game sounds about right but now d6
this is just not good by by lawrence queen
d2 take trade a pair rogues pawn on d5 this
move is fine as well like it's just this is
the wrong wrong stuff i think and nice move
of rook d6 if you took on d5 queen takes d8
was possible and two rooks for the queen so
instead we have this position where it's a solid
position for black white can't really move because
you don't want to drop the d5 pawn and look at
lawrence go though he's bringing the c-pawn up
the board i think he has some chances here as
he activates all of his pieces i i think that
this is a really bad position to be in for
lawrence this looks like a like a rook d5 hello
what's going on here it takes to take some b5 yeah
there's a queen eight check right at the end just
to win the b5 pawn yeah yeah he but this this is
just gonna go forever it's so so unfortunate king
somewhere he should have played c4 instead of
taking on d5 he actually had chances to outplay
roberto and i'm looking at the match clock
two minutes and almost 50 seconds now
he as soon as he finishes this game he and his
wife to draw he will need to win the one the next
one very quickly because he may run out of time
it just won't be possible i this is a bad sign
um the reason he took that is he wants to make the
draw quicker and if you trade the queens you can
do that however someone can absolutely still win
this game right and that someone looks more likely
to be roberto whose king is far more active let's
say you play f3 play g4 and there are some tricks
here yeah he's going for g [ __ ] he's going to
play a3 g4 or what i think so at least well the
a3 move i'm a little nervous to play because
it brings it closer to the enemy king but this
okay f5 okay this is oh it's getting closer if
you play a3 and then a5 a4 then white wind so a3
a6 and a4 a5 wow but now f4 check now you can
play 50 moves yes if you're if you're a bird
don't play 50 moves it's over the match definitely
definitely oh man you want to tilt lawrence trent
this is the way to do it he's played 49 moves and
then let your minute expire in the game the match
is over for sure right and honestly at this
point it already looks over because a minute
this is a master class on how to
send lawrence trent into orbit
yes because the pawns take away all
of the squares from the enemy king
and roberto did the right thing playing
out 50 moves and he could have wasted
all of the time yeah he could
have just sat there at the end
right there at the end you know now that the match
is his for the taking he could score a couple
extra bucks if he wins the final game because
the thing is if you're gonna be the guy who
plays those king moves and no judgment for me
at all on that but if you're gonna be that guy
why not also just waste the extra minute at the
end i mean there's there's no reason you don't
just end the match right there and it is the right
match strategy to play that out it would have been
it's it may seem improper or whatever
because they can agree on a draw but
it would have been bad for roberto's chances
because let's say they drew that game quickly
and then lawrence wins and he's time for one
more game you're doing a disservice to yourself
by the way this position is just
completely dominating for black
yeah unfortunately like this pawn is goner and
it's just all gonna be uh queen side play but
lawrence uh is not giving it his all because he
knows that the match clock is going to expire i
think i think he's very conscious of that and like
i said roberto couple extra dollars because the
winner gets half of the prize fund for winning
the match and then the other half is split by
win percentage so a final victory uh gives
him a little more money and for lawrence you
know he's gonna be just gutted after this and
we'll have both players on for an interview
of course like we always do but lawrence you know
he was up two games at two different points and
he was storming back in the bullet but it
wasn't enough and roberto just too powerful
yeah there comes the apon basically you had to
stop uh the pawn from getting to a2 this is over
yeah and he even stops for b3 and okay the match
is over both players know it and lawrence knows
that he had every chance in this match robert to
to make a combat to win this thing in every format
he was impressive he started out the five minute
ahead wait a minute he started out the five minute
the three minute and the one minute with with
a lead it's pretty impressive and you know well
he got to the one minute then he was he lost the
threat in the late stage of the three minute and
that's when roberto had the lead but we met like
he was ahead in each format so like he started
five minutes and in the five-minute games he he
started out with the lead in the three-minute
games he started out two and a half to half right
and in the bullet he started out with the win so
it's kind of like he had the hammer so to speak
to start things off for sure for sure he came out
in a winning streak that's absolutely the case
and we'll be right back because we're going to
bring both the players in for a post-match
interview will be very interesting to hear
their thoughts and especially from the emotional
lawrence trent but he gave it his all he did
and welcome back everybody we are uh lucky to
be joined by the players here for a post game
interview that's roberto molina and lawrence
trent are here with us and first of all of
course uh congrats to roberto for coming away
with the match victory but i'm actually going
to go over to you lawrence the the emotions from
you we can see them on the camera so i know that
there's probably a lot of thoughts going through
your head can you just take us through the match
maybe in your eyes because we we were just
witnessing you on camera going all over the
place reacting to some of those blunders uh flags
unfortunate situations that happen how do you feel
yeah basically if i didn't blunder a piece every
game i played i might be a good chess player you
know um i'll be honest i felt like i played in
general pretty pretty darn good chess i just
blundered all the time i lost on time in positions
i shouldn't have lost roberto was extremely fast
he put me under pressure i don't feel like roberto
completely outplayed me though from start to
finish i just was hanging pieces and that game
where i was the pawn up with the pawn on e4 and
losing that was just uh shocking um i was actually
really happy with the way i played in general
uh by the just ridiculous blunders and if i cut
those out i win the match by a by a long margin
but credit to roberto you know he uh he's stuck
in there even when he was uh he was worse and uh
even when he was behind and then there was that
stretch where he won four in a row that really
took it out of me we went into the bullet where
he had a two-point advantage and uh you know i
tried i i tried but he was just too quick he was
just a little too sharp in the bullet and i just
couldn't get the uh couldn't get the margin closer
so you know congrats to roberto but i do feel like
like i've lost a lot of matches before but
i'm i don't feel too bad with this one because
there were just so many stupid i mean literally
the most ridiculous hanging pieces hanging rooks
getting flagged how many points did i just burn uh
those you know i don't i feel like there are only
a handful of games where roberto truly outplayed
me without me blundering a piece that's my
interpretation maybe he's feeling something
different well roberto on your end you know
first of all congratulations you played it both
you played an excellent match and i want to ask
you because early on the games were very tactical
but then there were some games where you just said
no tactics for you i'm going to squeeze the second
game of the match for example and others as well
was that part of your strategy to avoid tactics
and to play more strategic battles yeah first
of all thanks or the opportunity to play again
and yeah general i am a positional player and
i prefer for example change queens played in
the game but in the beginning of the match uh
i can't i can't do that and he made me the
two first games and the preparation of opening
his total disaster in the beginning of the
match but i put my red in the right place
and try to try to fix this problem for
example change some moves or the in the open
right yeah it seemed like maybe you adjusted
some of the openings that lawrence was playing
he was able to get like really good
attacks especially in the early portion
um would you say that uh roberto in
the uh and the bullet was that of a
format that you were expecting to be able
to do better than lawrence in like you were
trying to keep the match close in blitz and then
wait for the bullet portion to score some points
um i think i just play one game after one
and the game and i i don't uh have a plan to
for example win the matching bullets i just
play one game and add order and another justice
yeah i mean my match plan obviously i looked at
roberto's games he is a very positional player
he likes drier positions so it was
absolutely clear to me that i had to take him
uh you know into a dogfight and get things messy
from the off and i was actually really happy with
uh with the openings i chose and i i think if
you remember my match against danny where he
didn't adjust roberto adjusted immediately
and that made a huge difference for phil
um he adjusted from game three he didn't give
me too many chances i had to work a lot and
there were a lot of these dry positions where
i just made classic mistakes i mean blundering
the rook on d4 to allow rook a8 allowing the
pawn on hc all of this stuff in blitz which
you shouldn't allow i allowed and you know
ultimately it was the blunders that cost me
although i think the the actual match was was
super close and if i'd avoided those i think i
think i would have won but that's that's the way
it goes it's blitz um at least at least it was
extremely competitive and i think the audience
would have had a great time watching these games
because there was i can't wait to look at these
games back because there are a lot of fireworks
everywhere even my first game i wanted to throw
my mouse out the window because i went king g3
and i wanted to go knight g3 obviously it was
just a mouse tip obviously i'm not going king g3
394 but anyway i mean there were certain
super fun games the one where i had the
queen on h g for all of this so i enjoyed
myself you know and credit to roberto
as i say startling guy uh tough guy to to beat
over a long stretch three hours is a long time
it's very intense and uh i wish him all the best
for the for the rest of the competition thanks
they change the mind in the for example
the karaoke defense this opening is my main
uh main weapon and you crushed me in the first
game i i think what it was what can i do now
it's amazing i do more preparation for
these matches than when i played for my
gm norms that's not even an exaggeration but
uh yeah super fun games a mix of everything so
uh yeah i'll go away with uh my head held high
lawrence quick question about that actually
because we were very impressed with both your
play it was a pretty hard fought match and
never felt like any side was running away with
it but you mentioned gm norms you very publicly
tweeted about how you know now is the time i'm
going to really dig deep and try to make that
grand master title yeah what has your work been
like how have you been preparing because the
preparation for this match looked good what's your
overarching plan looking like well i mean this i
mean just playing matches like this really gives
you the taste to want to go for it so uh basically
what i'm doing is i'm waiting it out just a
little longer until covid uh is is a bit more
clear obviously traveling around is still a little
bit tricky um so it's really i'm looking towards
the summer i'm going to be getting uh getting
a very famous coach to help me i've already
reached out to him he's already agreed um and
it's time to go for it because i think you know
if i cut out the silly mistakes you know i can
see it myself i can really play with these guys
robert so he's 27 50 20 under 2850 blitz player
i mean he's he's a super strong blitz player
super strong player in general and yeah as i
say um it's going to be a lot of adjustments
to get this gm title because i've got a lot of
points to make hundred points uh gotta get a norm
uh and it basically means effectively dropping
everything else uh doing doing a little things
on the side but for the most part just full full
steam ahead and i really want it now i'm in in the
right place in my life where i can do it i've got
the flexibility to do it so i'm just gonna do it
uh just gotta grab the bull by the horns amman
did it a few years ago i remember sweating amman
you know playing in all these swisses and isle
of man and everything else i saw him everywhere
grinding it's gonna take a crazy amount of volume
to get it as well i'm probably gonna have to play
200 games at least to even have a chance um
you know but hard work uh and and finding the
love for the game it's about that love and and
even today i really loved it i really enjoyed
playing some of those games so that's what it's
going to need and hopefully fingers crossed look
if you're out there and you're a naysayer you're
a debbie downer you're a you're a you're you know
you're a non-believer you know where i'm at
at lawrence trent i am on twitter hit me up
lines ready professional i've got a professional
handicapper who's doing the lines he's done all
the spreadsheets it's all ready i will i will
back myself if you don't think i can do it
come and hit me up because i've got a surprise
for you my friend i'm going to take that money and
i'm going to say i told you so that's it i like
that attitude for sure and roberto on your side
uh you're clearly a very strong player i believe
you have a couple norms what are your aspirations
like are you trying to become a grandmaster
as well yeah of course i have two gm norms and
i i just be studying streaming uh some
class and focus to improve my chest
but the problem here in
brazil don't have tournaments
i don't don't know when i will play again
for gm norms i think i need to travel
to europe i don't know but i am studying foreign
proof to improve my chest just this in the screen
just sounds like a good plan i guess we we
obviously wish you both the best and hope that we
can never invite either of you to this tournament
ever again um i am not a gm tournament but you
are gonna be continuing uh roberto in this event
so you're moving on to the next round you're the
first player uh to win their second round match
up and you'll be playing either lars oscar hauck
or teddy coleman in the next round have you seen
either of their previous matches or do you know
about anything uh anything about them as players
yeah i saw the the games uh just a little bit
of course but uh now uh i need to spread it for
example the openings and the style of playing
the positions and just wait for the next opponent
right yep it's a good way to do things take it one
match at a time as you said uh i echo uh robert's
comments earlier about how the match was honestly
one of the highest level matches we've seen every
match has blunders but seriously this match was
back and forth and it never felt like it was clear
until literally the last game of the match so
a big congrats to both of you lawrence sounds
like he had a great competitive time even
uh taking the loss there so best of luck on
the gm quest for both you and and thanks for
taking the time to play and share your thoughts
congrats again to you roberto thanks very much
all right and we've heard from the players there's
a really nice one to take take their time and
robert nice to see you nice to see uh lawrence
just have so much to say complimentary to his
opponent as well as indicating hey if i can
play chess like this i'm i'm ready for the
gm title yeah no the level of play was super high
in this one it's almost unfortunate that this was
the match up in a sense for both players because
they could have been eliminated and it's not that
they're any easy matchups but just something about
the stylistic imbalance here gave both players
chances we saw them thrive in their respective
elements and roberto when all was said and done
it did seem like he just barely eat this one out
and he was a deserved champion so i it wouldn't be
surprised no matter who won this match and now
that roberto has one you ask him what does he
think about the remaining competition after what
we saw today against a determined lawrence trent
yeah i'm not going to call him the favorite but
i don't see why anyone would be favored over him
either yeah that's a that's a great point as uh
he moves on in the bracket and uh we'll see who
he's up against there's lots more of these matches
coming up we've already highlighted and previewed
some of them but what an exciting match today i
think coming into this match you called it and
you were pretty much spot on that this was one of
the hardest ones to guess who was going to be the
winner because we know that lawrence can come
in and not be playing his best and maybe it's
a white watch but when lawrence is focused and
he was today he said he does more prep for this
than his gm norm tournament uh and i love to
see lawrence when he's that motivated playing
that type of chess so i thought that lawrence
is showing in this entire tournament his match
against danny as well as this one is something to
be proud of absolutely and for roberto you know
in the post-match interview essentially he was
just very casual about it you know i'm studying
i'm getting ready i'm always working on my
chest i'm streaming now which is great to hear
and i hope that he continues his success because
that level of play that we saw today i know it
sounds like we've mentioned it many times but it's
just true i was really impressed by how sharp both
players were early in the game or in the match
i should say roberto was finding these pins
out of nowhere and just being tactically alert and
lawrence was drumming a play out of nowhere coming
up with blistering attacks with that one game
with queen d7 knight f4 queen h3 where roberto
ended up losing on time so both players showed
their strengths i think that blunders as you
mentioned many times they happen right we expect
that to happen but i was like really thrilled to
see both players compete so fiercely yep and
this was uh you know that that'll be it for us
wrapping uh things up here i guess the match
finished 12 to nine uh overall so uh roberto
molina is gonna move on to the next round and uh
when those matches happen you know either robert
and myself or another commentary team will be here
to guide you through the the tricky calculations
and bring you all the action but robert it was
a pleasure pleasure as always today uh this was
probably one of the most exciting matches chess
wise that i've had the pleasure to commentate
yeah and there's i can't think of anyone else
i'd rather jump back in my chair alongside
when some of these shocking things happen but
i'm on seriously it was a great time the players
treated us so it made our lives easy and thanks
of course to all the fans who continue to tune
in watch these players root them on we can
feel your energy so we really appreciate that
yep well take care guys um there's going to be
lots more of these matches coming up so make
sure to stay tuned in and of course there's all
those regular chess.com events that are coming
up as well as the regular ones on the calendar
title tuesday arena kings so just so much chess
happening guys stay tuned and uh that's all for us
for now take care guys and we'll see you next time